wow
wow
two
well well well here we are it's monday
january 24th
the gang's all here love is here
and love is in the building too i got a
bowl of brown and green eminent oh i
guess well you guys see them as blue
they're getting keyed out oh yeah good
point honestly it's probably good
because it's just not it's not it's way
too provocative this show yeah in fact
should we even be talking about this the
circle we should blur this bowl yeah
blur this bowl okay cabinet post
it's way too sexy these glasses have
changed my life
oh
interesting
welcome everybody it's h3tv
hope you all had a blessed weekend
today's episode is sponsored by hello
fresh me undies mint mobile and
love them love them reminder
call in
to the show today 808 hot meme
taking calls now
hey everybody
that's your [ __ ] call today h3 tv
all right
um
everyone have a good weekend
indeed well yeah yes i did i can't speak
for everyone though i know some of us
did not have a good weekend but more
airbnb drama oh yeah from the boys
horrible horrible weekend you want to
give us an update on the airbnb
so
short and sweet we got kicked out from
our airbnb just randomly no one day
noticed we had to leave
and it wasn't even the host's fault it
was actually airbnb's fault who decided
to just
end that listing because apparently it
was going against tos
do you know what was the violation or no
do you think it had anything to do with
us talking about it and people mass
flagging i have i think so yeah i think
that was the case
cam doesn't think so um well then how
else do you explain such a radical
by the way you guys they didn't want to
move okay so don't come for me like and
yeah no no don't call for anyone
please
yeah anyways yeah they just randomly
kicked us out and one day noticed on a
on a sunday afternoon super random yeah
we were i was going to take uh
love out to venice beach to
to see some sites in la and stuff and
then i got a message from them in the
morning just like uh we're actually you
have to move today so
so they give you a notice they said you
have to move up by end of day
asap within hours yeah it was like
literally like you need to get out now
yeah
because that listing is gone from airbnb
they don't offer that airbnb anymore and
it's not the host's fault i want to make
this very clear it's not actually the
host's fault directly at least
airbnb decided to cancel that listing
completely for whatever reason while
there was two people living in it
and they i guess that's awesome how you
guys been absolutely screwed by airbnb
on both ends now so crazy
that's the thing about i hate airbnb i
hate airbnb i'll just say i hate it i
had a horrible experience with them
there's just no regulation it's like
you know
you guys have a long-term rental and
then both the
site and the user can just be like you
have to leave in an hour there's just
it's just they're crazy crazy i guess
they they said that it doesn't like
hold up to our standards anymore so you
guys better live on the streets instead
that's better standards right that's
what i love about it is like it's not up
to our standards but what is up to our
standards is kicking you out in 30
minutes they're like well there's a tent
encampment down the street that might
suit you right right right your needs a
bit cheaper too
can you make clear please that guys i
i tried to get him to come get out they
didn't want to get out they're coming
for me
did i hear them sharpening their
pitchforks yeah see
no one is at fault here no no be
specific i've gotten help to move
wherever i want to
i i got you i could send ethan offered
to find them a place thank you maybe
their pool house if need be whatever
they need to try get them off the
streets
you're such a good guy and i've also
seen some hate for what i do cameron
before wait why are people hating
cameras because he he's like my
apparently my like
guide here
yeah it's not as bad as i made it sound
out it's not nearly yeah
by the way i i didn't know where it was
okay and first you know what i'm not
entertaining you the worst of you okay
shut up you know i'm taking care of them
they're fine leave me the frick alone
dude and i see a lot of comments on
behind the scenes because i showed a
little bit of the airbnb and they're
like wow this place is really nice it
was nice yeah okay leave me alone that's
the real idea of it
it's like yeah it's in a bad
neighborhood it's in los angeles it's
all about neighborhood yeah for people
who are unaware there was a lot of
people who are angry at me for letting
them stay in such a run down
we were playing it up for the show too
we're just yeah
well
the thing with downtown is that just a
couple blocks away from downtown it gets
really gnarly but when you live in like
further more local in downtown it's
actually like a decent neighborhood yeah
changes from block to block yeah exactly
so we were living in a fine place we
don't live there anymore for that fact
anyways so it doesn't matter so you guys
found a new place cam said uh yes yes
we do is it now how now the proximity to
skid row how mad are people going to be
at me for this new player well
you might catch some heat for this one
but i do think it's a slightly better
place okay good so
but you know you you might get some hate
though i don't know you know well that's
up to you love how you want to frame it
well i'm very happy to just be here i
never
hate it on anyone just for the uh yeah
no
i'm bringing a bunch of [ __ ]
yeah right well said
and you're wearing a mask so people can
actually tell if you said it or not
right exactly this is not good [ __ ]
yeah this is baby world you know you
could be popping at any time which is
kind of crazy her due date is on
well her due date is on a week from
today
we're in the danger zone
we're definitely in the danger zone now
where all hell is about to break loose
[Music]
i think how good that clickbait will be
though ela's water broke on the show
today
epic wait parentheses epic
you won't believe what happened next
stay down [ __ ] baby
oh my
[Laughter]
god yeah um so that's my life basically
just enjoying my last moments of like
sanity here
but i'm so excited to meet little baby
bruce
kind of recapping from last week
uh zach cut a little heat on uh his
antics from last week i did yeah how are
you feeling zach i just i i
after the episode ian and i and sam
spoke on the phone and you know publicly
i do want to apologize to sam and ian
for how i was reacting what did i miss
what did you catch me dude i don't think
you have to apologize honestly yeah like
i don't believe all the [ __ ] zach gets
zach is the kind of soul i probably ever
met it drives me insane like i don't i
don't know what it is well how you
always get [ __ ] for nothing
i actually don't think you need to
apologize either i mean okay i retracted
that yeah retract okay i retracted
actually spit on them i confused what
he's apologizing for because of the
steak antics people
took it we're like they're like sam made
him that steak and he didn't need it
sam you weren't upset that he ate the
steak it was just we're just doing goofs
right yeah we uh we called zach after
and we were like because we saw some of
those comments and we were like what the
hell we didn't care that's fine
they tore my boy up on reddit yeah
exactly
they cooked zach more than that steak
yeah that zach was cooked like uh
straight straight
well done they made him reared my boy we
were having fun you know and it's just i
i i didn't mean to make you feel bad sam
or anything like because i would never
do that
you didn't though we all know you know
right we're right but you know it could
be viewed that way so i mean i
we're all good i promise i was not
offended at all okay well there you go
that's good thank you sam oh i love
salmon but the thing is zach i i my take
on that situation was that you were
actually having
you're actually very superstitious
you didn't want to get the curse from
the stake that was my read yes and i
find that interesting i wanted to unpack
that experience okay okay but it
actually it was it was i guess you could
say it was played up but it was real the
tension was real and that zach did not
want to eat the steak i i
once ian said you're [ __ ] that's why
that's when i spit it out the thing is
too i want to clarify like
i asked sam afterwards too
i wasn't trying to mess with zach really
like [ __ ] no we had that conversation
after where
i thought it just was like a badass rock
looking case like one of zach's favorite
band's tool has a lot of stuff that
looks like that right you said it alex
gray yeah yeah so i was like oh this is
kind of like a cool thing and zach wants
a steak so
to add an element because everyone else
got like weird stuff
so i was like well i can't just give
zach like a badass suitcase because
everyone got like a
factor of it so that was like to add a
layer to it but i really wasn't trying
to give him anything like curse it just
kind of turned into that on the show so
really yeah really i just because i
didn't want to be like and for zach
here's like a badass suitcase that thing
is cursed bro stop it look at that
that's that's that's the one that's
actually not the one
that's not the one we got i pulled this
up because a fupa trooper emailed me oh
a collection
coincidentally
said that their father is friends with
the original artist that made these
cases and they've had this in their
garage for years they just happen to
have one of the same make it might be
valuable i've been getting people
messaging me offering to buy it i mean
you might want to antics roadshow that
[ __ ] before you sell it i find it i'm
thinking how i could flip it one person
like offered their guitar for it and
offering
trades i really thought it was just like
a cool suitcase no
in retrospect yeah but the way you were
presenting it like i thought i perceived
it as a curse well i was like me too
well you walked over and the first thing
out of your mouth was like don't [ __ ]
mess with me because i had it in the
comedy show so then what that's what we
play off of right so we weren't
intending it was very funny that now
you're [ __ ] that was good that's see
that's why i spit the steak out just to
clarify just yeah it was obvious well
you came in like so scared of me and i
wasn't
i don't know what you're up to
i thought the cursed item of the day was
going to be the big rat to be honest
that's what i wanted you know it's funny
the rat is good vibes i'm looking at it
right now i'm down with the rat yeah the
rat is good vibes like i was a little
baffled uh when i opened it but uh but i
don't hate the rat well anyway um i was
feeling a little bad for zach uh there
was a lot there were some mean comments
and uh
we love our boys well thank you i
appreciate that controversy
where you've been there
i would have joined in yeah you would
have got on your head
[ __ ] this guy yeah he sucks
yeah i don't i don't know what i did to
necessarily deserve all that hate or
heat but um we're all good between sami
and i just for the thank god the record
yeah uh by the way i'm gonna need your
uh
two-week sack
just kidding you got a resignation on my
desk by the morning
yeah i saw this really funny thing
unrelated but this girl
she was printing out a letter of
resignation for her boyfriend
and she sent it to her boss to
print it without giving him context so
she sends him an attachment that says
letter resignation and in the body of
the email just says yo can you print
this for me
which is like the most badass way to
quit a job
and the boss was like are you like what
kind of perverted power play is this
i thought it was so funny yo can you
print this for me
awesome
yeah we got a lot to talk about today
uh oliver is coming on is it tomorrow
he's coming tomorrow the episode will be
out on thursday yeah
i don't know if he's still coming after
what was going on this weekend though
yeah there's a lot of beef there's a lot
of controversy back and forth on twitter
of me and oliver what the [ __ ] he's just
starting it's he's always starting
trying to start [ __ ]
unbelievable we've been exposing each
other
chances are good obviously that he will
be here tomorrow and we'll have a show
on thursday but the funny thing about
this is that me and oliver were arguing
back and forth right and guess who
guess
guess who
is the biggest [ __ ] in the world
keemstar actually retweeted an oliver
tree tweet
talking smack about me he said dear
ethan you're the definition of fake news
i never once begged to be in your shitty
podcast we all know the only reason you
can afford to pay your producers because
ila made teddy fresh it's only a matter
of time before she dumps your ass gonna
be broken alone and keemstar retweeted
that bro
how stupid would it tell me
my jaw dropped when i saw that oh he
untweeted it real fast but we caught him
stupid [ __ ]
god he's got to feel dumb doesn't he
i don't know if he is self-aware enough
to
i don't know if he has feelings
um he um
he did follow this up with the tweet
saying like acknowledging like i don't
care if it's fake everything he said was
100 true or something like that yeah so
what
wait that eat that the only reason i'm
successful is because of ela and soon
i'll be alone and yeah yeah it's all
true 100 true
love that for him
gabe took my advice
hell yeah
it's on tick tock too can you find the
tick tock link i want to see because
gabe is being apparently he's being um
blacklisted on tick tock and then
because you know you hear that a lot
from creators and you never know what's
true or not but love you said every time
you post white club gabe
it gets taken down yeah i posted
probably
a four white card game post in the past
couple months or i guess before before
the break and all of them got taken down
and we got banned
unbelievable
and it's just him cursing doing his
normal things yeah just him doing his
own like a normal thing some i think one
was when he was on our show got taken
down and we got a like a three-day ban
whoa yeah like they're ruthless over
there why do they hate gabe i don't know
he's such a sweetheart
anyway here's the video
dang it's monday pissing my ass yes
pissing my ass that's good sunday
the toilet baby pissing my ass
pissing my ass pissing my ass
yeah the toilet
yeah the toilet it's monday pissing my
ass it's monday pissing my ass pissing
my ass my day buddy [ __ ]
what's wrong with that
all right we got the tick tock let's see
if it's blowing up
oh i think i think he did i think he was
wise to follow my advice
i think this is going to go viral dang
it's monday pissing my ass i mean
okay all right okay okay all right
baby okay i'm trying to pause it
it's only been up three hours so it's
hard to tell if this is gonna go viral
or not
he put up another one where he says it
the one after that or he told tom brady
to piss in his ass oh for real
i'm having a happy monday you know why
because [ __ ] tom brady yeah [ __ ] tom
brady yeah tom brady you are pissing my
ass
[ __ ] you tom brady [ __ ] you
that's
i'm having
tick tock just leave me alone bro
nothing you do is good on
desktop
yeah his views are suffering man
hate to see it
not cool
they really are blue balling them it
looks like
like his last banger was steak night
baby let's see does he curse on steak
night hurry up gabe
put the steak back on the [ __ ] grill
yeah
horses you dumb [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] let's go is that
done
ah that's not done yet a little more a
little bit more all right
hurry up yeah that was a good one
maybe he's cursing too much maybe he
just needs to tone it down a little bit
my ass
maybe that's vulgar the piss in my ass
that is very
vulgar
could someone turn the ac off i'm
freezing my my dick off my dick looks
like an acorn right now
thank you a.b hi i'm dick tiff
well i hope um
i hope that works out for gabe you know
he really deserves he really deserves to
be seen yeah
you want to do a breakdown maybe of
something that happened with gabe yeah
just that moment is one of my favorite
moments in podcast history really and
the audience doesn't know that he was
supposed to say something when he sat
down and hear your reaction was
priceless you want me to play it yeah
yeah okay so maybe maybe wants to give
commentary on this do you want audio or
no audio with audio okay gabe was
supposed to sit there and say something
like i'll help you [ __ ] or
something like that
but then he just didn't say anything
and your reaction was priceless thank
you bro
baby's full of positivity today
this was great
[Applause]
that's why we're all giggling yeah
that's why we're dying in the background
are you going to say anything i want to
say fried chicken friday
yeah
it's friday yeah he was supposed to be
like did somebody say fried chicken yeah
something like that and i reminded him
right before he sat down but it was so
funny it was even better he's a
sweetheart he's a pure soul piss my ass
baby
[ __ ] supposed to be fight chicken
wednesday if i'll say fight chicken
friday baby
yeah good times good times
love that man
yeah we got a lot to talk about today
lots of fun goofs gaffes today we're
going to be talking i don't know if you
guys been following this fresh and fit
podcast i'm we're going to talk about
that these guys are like
straight gamma males
or black i don't know i guess i don't
know what a game of male is i'm oh you
don't well we're gonna get to that tim
pool said i'm a gamma male in response
to me right uh
deleting or unlisting two episodes with
jordan peterson and i googled it and i
gotta say there's a lot there's a lot of
conflicting information out there about
what constitutes a gamma male so yeah
they got to get their they got to get on
the same page there so we're going to
talk about fresh and fit we're going to
talk about sexy m ms that are ruining
america uh you know and the cult the
ongoing cultural war of the right
there are certain lines you just do not
cross and one of them is you do not make
the green and brown eminem less sexy
hershey's it's invisible it's hershey's
right
uh it's actually the mars company oh the
mars company basically they made the m
m's the green and the brown less sexy
and the right is just fuming
i'm a little unclear on how the brown
one's sexiness was toned down it looks
pretty much the same to me i think just
the shoes change she was wearing like
sexy stilettos
and then she was wearing sneakers no
that's the green one all right we'll
take a look we'll get into that that's
coming up
and the metaverse of course uh is always
fantastic it's popping in the metaverse
baby
yeah there's a cl so funny but um let's
see
um
oh i'm not logged into the call thing
dan oh i got you
yeah i wanna there's a tick tock account
i've been following okay and i want you
guys to weigh in
this guy
just trying to make the sound so it
doesn't get claimed uh there's this guy
superman joe
who's like this jacked
little
i don't know if he's short he's jacked
he's five nine i saw i did a little
digging he is okay
so he's five nine of like straight
muscle
but the way he jumps
doesn't look real and i don't think it
is
i actually think that there's something
fishy going on here are you done hacking
my computer dan uh no okay well give me
a sec let me put something on
all right let's start from the top
if i go back
you tell me if this is real or fake
there's just no way there's just no way
um
here let's start with this i guess
that's fake
no he can't nobody can jump like that
it's like he defies gravity
also
i feel like if you're that
muscular it's harder
to jump because he's got so much extra
weight on the top portion of his body
you know like when you look at gymnasts
they're very slim
because
it's way easier to do all these crazy
tricks and stuff i mean that makes sense
there's no freaking way
i just
i'm looking at an angle from
like how
you would fake it i mean unless he's
wearing some sort of like
i mean do they make shoes that make it
easier to jump higher or something you
got moonshine does it look real i mean i
don't know what is here let me pull up
the i'm curious what the people say
um but okay this is just one
this is just one example and everyone's
in disbelief that man just levitated
yeah
the dude is bouncy this guy's got
flubber on his shoes
i definitely think this is real how
i've just i've just seen people jump
like that before i think it's about hops
yeah i've seen short people especially
doing backflips like that
i don't know
do you want to do a pull you want to
pull hold on hold on before we do a pull
let's look at more evidence okay but
what's really even more mysterious about
it is like how muscular he is that's
just extra weight
he's got
he's gotta pull up there and like watch
how his legs go back it doesn't make
sense who jumps like this look how he
puts his legs back he levitated at the
top he like literally froze watch this
he literally
double jumped look at this
yeah i think it's slowed down when he's
something is going on here
king kong ain't got [ __ ] on me look how
his legs go back nobody jump like that
[Music]
dude
jordan does
pull up jordan dunking let's do a
comparison i don't think people put
their legs back like they're doing like
a wee he's like wee
i said ab i thought he looks like a uh
like a fighting game character totally
the way they like jump
you can
straight up
it looks like he has
wires attached to him you know what i
mean
yeah but they're here let's keep going
over the evidence and you guys decide
also his whole shtick is superman joe
right i mean
i don't know
i'm not buying it
here's another one it's either
i see a few people saying it's
in reverse
i don't know how that would
help that was my initial thought but i
was paying attention to the background
like the basketball the fan i don't know
how that would work yeah this one is
like pretty crazy but
it's i guess believable it's really the
the vertical leaps that sketch me out
maybe he's just got mad hops i think
he's just yeah i think he's just
crazy fit
i found a photo of jordan duncan just
like that okay let's see
no it's not like he does
his legs are here let me show this okay
his legs are like bent at a 90 degrees
also that's michael jordan
but okay right i mean
this guy's superman yeah that's true if
yeah here he is dunking again the pole
seems divided i'm seeing a lot you see
how his legs go literally vertical
like str i mean like 90 degree
nobody jumped like this
somebody said he's an omicron male
dude he double jumps he like goes higher
than he should like watch this his his
max height ends
like here
but he goes higher
why does he go higher
dude he has like a
i think because it's just slowed down at
that moment it gives an illusion that
he's going higher
i see what you're talking about
um
[Music]
what's the poll let me i gotta open the
i don't buy this stuff there's something
fishy does anyone back
in the poll here
uh
i'm like
i'm i think it's real but i'm not like
super confident about it like it it does
look strange but it looks so sexy
the thing is i can't identify but
nothing happens
what the fake is so yeah that's the
problem back from it's hard
it would be really hard to fake that
right in that setting with all those
people and everything yeah i mean
not impossible by any means but it would
take a decent amount of effort well
let's keep going superman joe right
superman joe real or fake
oh
real
fake
all right let's ask
the community
polls going up duh i mean i don't know
dude it's just
i refuse to believe that people can do
this
in the real world
okay how about this one check this one
out i think i saw this one
is this the one i saw
there's one where he does a push-up like
all the way standing like look how he
does a push-up
hold on
he does a push-up basically to standing
nobody i'd have never seen anybody do
that look at this
what
this guy's superman i mean there's no
explanation
i don't buy it this shit's fake
always be
so he's got to be shirtless shut up look
how his legs go back what is that
people are saying it's real okay
yeah i mean i mean it's a decent third
of the audience thinks it's fake it's
not it's not a blowout but
it just
okay well it seems like
i mean the i think the consensus is that
it's real based on the con i don't see
people in the comments talking about how
it's fake and anything like that i guess
i'm the only one
well not necessarily explicitly that
it's fake but
almost all of the do you know what
that's our saying like this is
unbelievable or you know what it is it
looks like he's on a trampoline it looks
like he's jumping off sure right
a trampoline
okay
shout out superman joe i guess
keep a close eye on him we're gonna
expose superman joe
yeah i think it's fake too just for you
you do okay love
backing me up i don't know i've been
blown away by like
gfx and before like dude this is fake
this is fake that might be in reverse
every time i see him jump up on
something it looks like it's in reverse
i agree that one looks reversed like
watch this
dude
that's like that's edited somehow
there's no freaking way
that one on the other hand where he ran
that's possible but where he stood still
and jonathan
norway it doesn't look real
100
i don't believe it you guys want to
change your votes in the chat let me
back me up how would you reverse this
one right here
what would another point
of just doing this one here
that one is sketching us out and that
one and that one is probably real i'm
sure he's like really juiced up he can
probably jump very far but
some of these nah
hell no thank you love
you're promoted
thank you
anyway regardless if it's real fake
interesting eh
pretty incredible either way
yeah true i mean
if it is fake it's an unbelievable fake
and if it's real
i saw somebody we say we gotta ask we
gotta get captain disillusion on this
huh
he would know that's a good idea yeah
send him this video specifically because
i feel like this is the best
example maybe
those first two jumps right what the
freak what the freak
i took a jumping potion you guys
keep playing what the heck
olivia said if he's that talented why
isn't he an olympian or something
well
[Music]
is there
i mean there's the high jump but the
high jump in the olympics is like with a
pole right there's not like is is there
a sport for just a standing high jump
like that uh not that i know of i don't
know
i don't know man the muscle thing makes
it impossible to do jumps like that
because he's got like he's probably got
like a hundred pounds of extra weight in
his upper body
where if you look at professional
jumpers their upper body they're they're
obviously extremely fit but they're slim
okay
to kind of support what you're saying
this is interesting this is a video from
2016 guinness world record
standing jump i don't want to show much
because guinness claims so i'm only just
going to show i have a queued up i'm
just going to just make it smaller
they won't uh okay they won't recognize
the oh god oh god that's good
see that
how high was that
let me see that again you use audio and
let me i want to watch this [ __ ]
but to support what you're saying look
how skinny he is he's not he's not and
also look how hard that [ __ ] is
it didn't look like he was levitating or
floating right okay so that's about the
same height as him let's compare how far
did the other you jump was that the same
height as him too let's do the mask one
the the scare mask
dude look at him he literally jumps
higher than he's levitating to it
it's the muscles that make it impossible
it really is
can you get doing impossible things men
are long jumping
they're doing impossible things jumping
six meters straight have you ever seen
superman joe do a 12 foot vertical
he deserves a mass community he deserves
to get laid
can you pull up a picture of the
guinness world record guy search his
name let's look at his physique
superman joe is inspiring me
i've been doing squats every day
i still don't have the same vertical
yeah this is a conspiracy
so the record in that video was 63.5
inches so that would be uh
five foot three roughly did this rise up
okay so do we know what these boxes are
because
he's doing
we can calculate how tall he's going
because he's doing like one two three
and more do does anyone know what these
jumping boxes are well we know like i
said i think i identified
that he is five foot nine
he's easily jumping his height so is it
his own height because then that would
beat the record the supposed record of
five foot three
yeah either this guy's the greatest
athlete that ever lived
well maybe i mean
it's possible maybe he is
up wake up
superman joe wake up
yeah you see how skinny he is yeah i
mean this is the guy from again no extra
weight no extra weight up top
[Music]
that is pretty tall can we see it from
this profile i want to see him jump that
that's really tall
or he's relatively short i mean this is
supposed to be five foot three and
oh man maybe he is real short maybe he's
only like five four five five so short
guys got the best hop per capita per
inch pound for bound
i guess there's maybe an argument for
that i mean i don't know
just the right height you got me
thinking though i don't know oh god
god damn yeah so am i planting doubt i
mean guys
i like i said i was never fully
convinced it was real i just couldn't i
couldn't see the edit so i i was
if we can find out what these jumping
boxes are we can determine how tall is
he really jumping how high doesn't it
say how tall they are on the side of
them
isn't that the length can we zoom in
this is like a big enhanced enhancement
it just says three two one i don't see
anything else no that's i don't know
what that means but yeah you should be
able to find these
j r h
just the right height
people saying reverse it
i mean here i can reverse it with my
slider bar i think
okay ready
oh that looks pretty weird
and reversed didn't it well that that
last one is the one that we were saying
look legit because he has a running
start okay so wait let's go
that one looked like he jumped backwards
straight the f up
that dude jumped backwards
interesting
that one did look pretty natural and
this one too
look
oh
might be on to something there the thing
is he is really good at jumping so he
sells it
right i have no doubt that he is a high
jumper but it you know isn't being
artificially inflated a little bit you
tell me which looks faker this
or this the the straight jump looks fake
the back jump looks real
got him
thank you you guys feel free to change
your vote anytime people saying the
numbers on the side are the feet so i
mean it would be yeah
that would be six feet then yeah over
plus plus a half oh
come on there ain't no way
the world record that means he just beat
the world record by like a foot yeah
there's no shot you guys yeah change
your votes right now i swear to god the
reel has been dipping it's down to 58
percent you all change your votes right
now
this man
just broke the world record by over a
foot i'd like to see him do it in person
well let's cut let's reach out i'd like
to see him do it actually that's the
only way to verify right get this man
and you know what dude superman joe you
come on our show you do the jump and
we'll get the guinness world record out
here too because if you are doing this
for real we need you we need you in the
history books
oh yeah god do it live
okay
so hassan tried to just so he's so tall
i don't think hassan's got jumps just a
guess because again he's got the muscles
you can't you just have extra weight
yeah i'm reading something else that
sometimes shorter athletes have a
superior strength to weight ratio when
compared to taller ones
results in a relatively greater ability
to perform explosive movements like
vertical jumps
[Laughter]
it's funny
anyway interesting eh
people are saying new poll all right
let's do a new poll real fast
and then guys let's try to reach out to
superman joe if we can get an end person
uh jump
uh jumping exhibit
exhibition otherwise captain disillusion
we gotta get him on everyone we're
getting ahold of everyone
we need to know the truth
the truth will set you free the truth is
out there
new poll going up ask jordan peterson if
you guys can send this video to him
all right round two superman joe let's
see what we get all right guys you know
what to do i've played my evidence
forward i have expressed with with
sincerity i have told you how and why
this jump is fake
i have shown you undeniable evidence
unless this man just broke the world
record by a whole foot
with a hundred pounds of muscle
we don't know that
a hundred percent
making a making a guess the heights of
those boxes yeah making a guess does
that make sister sense it does make
sister sense thank you we i've
successfully um argued my case
71 says fake how are you
love that
love that
love that so let's reach out let's see
if we can get superman joe in here
jumping that would be sick i mean that'd
be great yeah i'd love to see that
we have a new brought bradbury is this
good i just saw the thumbnail is this
whole raw theory any good yeah i saved
it for the show i i wanted to i wanted
to go in raw so i screened it
uh there are some stuff we have to skip
i have a time stamp but it is pretty
good oh no it's it's like the
culmination of everything he's done it's
all led to this video really well that's
exciting
let's watch it at the end i'm not ready
for the raw theory
what
you want to watch the whole thing right
now how long is it no you can't watch
anything there's a lot of copyright
i just saw the thumbnail and was like
dude what god's name cause they've
always been kind of what's the word
um homoerotic with each other
oh yeah and so
it's really just
it's really just the thumbnail that
caught me by oh somebody says those are
metas plyo boxes and the 321 is only 90
centimeters 90 centimeters is only three
feet wait what there's no way those were
three feet it looked like the same
height as him
so anyway what do you guys think about
this thumbnail the raw theory
i mean i love it
first of all looks like euphoria new
episode
it looks like yeah
okay this is exactly what it was thank
you guys wait a minute
it does say 45 centimeters 30
centimeters 15 shoulders so if you add
all that up where where does that not be
six feet
here
with it why does it look so tall what is
he four feet tall so maybe
trick of the camera angle or something
i mean are those the same boxes i mean i
know it looked identical similar
it's got to do it live that's the only
way to tell
they look
here let me pull it up the screen one
here
now it looks identical the box is down
well that would be only like three feet
oh you know it could be different uh
different size
same company different size boxes
yeah
because these actually say the
measurement on the side and those don't
so
so what is he super tiny like super tiny
90 centimeters that's nothing
it's like three feet what a twist
it's only three pieces something's not
adding up here i think i think we can
all agree right
those those
those barbells next to him those those
are actually just like little handheld
i mean what's what's odd is the three
there's definitely
he's jumping further away from these
boxes these boxes are lined up here
and he's not like
the three one is closer than the one
don't you think no i'm just gonna go
with the theory that he's three feet
tall and he's interested yeah that would
explain if he was
the basketball
court and like that's just like a nerf
uh you know like little kids basketball
court that they've set up
it's a bottle
basketball bottle yeah
okay
thank you
uh we should do uh ads all right let's
do two ads real fast when we come back
we'll get right back into
um
all the good stuff eh lots of good stuff
so first thank you to hello
fresh fresh fresh fresh fresh fresh
fresh fresh fresh
hello fresh with hell fresh you get farm
fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
doorstep skip trips to the grocery store
and count on hella fresh to make home
cooking fun
easy and affordable for example abe made
this burrito
how was that burrito
it was amazing yeah i can never forget
it looks good
that's right it's america's number one
meal kit
you know hello fresh cuts back on time
spent in the kitchen so you can spend it
in your on other resolutions you've got
when you got meals ready and under 30
minutes or less plus quick and easy
meals
including 20-minute recipes and low prep
easy clean up options provide an even
faster route to putting food on the
table and don't forget dessert
satisfying your sweet tooth with
seasonal limited time goodies like
dunkaroos
dunkaroos cookie dough or vanilla
delight cheesecake
i love hello fresh oh wow this is a new
one eh
what is that pork is that pork
uh looks like pork chops or something
yeah damn so this is what i'm talking
about this is from the super troopers
god bless them thank you guys chicken
tacos they send you a whole box of
groceries exactly portioned out
um
full of dry ice so it stays nice and
fresh send it to your door
and they send you the perfect amount of
ingredients they send you instructions
it's a fun fulfilling experience or
you're making fresh delicious food you
don't have to go to the grocery store
you don't have to over buy groceries so
it tends to even be more affordable
um
i am a huge fan of hellofresh i've
enjoyed and loved every time i've used
it and i've learned a lot from about
cooking too if you don't know anything
about cooking it's an easy dub go to
hellofresh.com
slash h3tv 16 and use code
h3h3tv16 and get up to 16 free meals and
three free gifts
guys hellofresh.com h3tv16
use code h3
h3tv16 for up to 16. free meals it's
hello fresh america's number one meal
kit thank you also a nice sexy little
song is there a new one that we're using
today yeah yeah we'll try something new
and my feelings with this one
me undies
someone you love in a relationship with
somebody who tells the same joke over
and over
okay
am i uh being uh
called out targeted
or are they uh with somebody who has the
audacity to starfish the bed
now be honest is this somebody you
relationships are not perfect that's why
me undies is celebrating our
imperfections
perfect match
with this new valentine's day collection
okay
chill
just call me out better buy you some
underwear oh those are sick
um me undies is amazing soft
uh it's just so soft it's like underwear
you've never worn before it's this high
quality
the prints are awesome
you know so many of us are just lugging
around the same old hanes underwear that
you bought from macy's you know 20 years
ago it's time to upgrade where adults
impress your significant other with some
badass grown up underwear that feels
great
and a breeze baby
you know gifting underwear for think
about it dude right gifting underwear
for valentine's day it's groundbreaking
but gifting matching underwear for you
and your significant other now we're
talking
express your one-of-a-kind relationship
when you match your bottom half to your
better half and a full limited edition
print and if you're single and ready to
mingle and matching pairs with your
friends or fam don't mean yeah i okay
you can even get dog hoodies or buddy
bands to match your four-legged bff and
be sure to check out all the mandy super
cute and super soft undies socks
bralettes loungewear and more available
in sizes extra small to 4xl mnd says a
great offer for our listeners for a
limited time get 25 off your first order
of matching pairs for valentine's day
and as a first time purchase purchaser
you also get 15 off and free shipping
right to your door to get 25 off
matching pairs 50 off your first order
and free shipping and 100 satisfaction
guaranteed go to meundies.com h3tv
that's meundies.com h3 tv
[Music]
um
why does valentine's day have to be
in february
right after we get off
all of these
holidays
in like no
from like october through february like
the holidays are too clustered we need
to spread these out throughout the year
more you're saying i think the theory if
there is a theory is that like spring
and summer are great everyone's happy in
spring and summer because the weather's
nice
and then when winter and and uh
and you know december starts getting
cold and dark you need the holidays to
have something to look forward to to
cheer you up but what if i mean if you
don't have a significant other then
valentine's day is just like a spit in
the face in like the darkest time of the
year already i mean valentine's day is
kind of a [ __ ] oh holiday let's be
honest it is
at least
i mean i'm looking at the calendar we
it's a desert from like
late june until september basically we
get fourth of july that's it and it's
not really a gift-giving holiday you
know
no but i'm just i'm happy i don't need a
holiday
things rule dude it's june it's summer
baby yeah sunny
it's good
winter comes around dark
cold then you go it's christmas we got
christmas to look forward once christmas
is over christmas good day i mean
christmas depression christmas has
priority for sure but valentine's day i
mean this is artificial holiday anyways
it's like why not it could have been a
little more strategic about it that's
all i'm saying could be a may holiday
yeah may
you know
who do we talk to about changing this
let's leave valentine's where it is for
now and
all right we'll we'll put a pin in this
yeah put a pin in that we'll come back
can i watch this local news reporter hit
by car
uh
i think we have to it's not it's you'll
see it it's not very violent newschannel
3's story orgy joins us now live in
dunbar and jory they're not seeing any
flakes but wet roads and now we're
starting to experience unfortunately in
freeze thaw we see this water main
breaks
[Laughter]
what the hell is that
hold on that guy did not even react
he did not even get phased by that not
even a little bit
woohoo
i just got hit by a card
[Music]
you're okay we're all good
wow man this is straight uh anchorman
[ __ ] i mean that guy does not have an
operating brain cell in his head
teleprompter and that's it
imagine you're on a phone call with
somebody who gets hit by a car and your
reaction is just
huh we'll do it live huh
wow
he hits her with a wow in a second
wow keep watching
we're good
man you are so sweet and you are okay
what a trooper she is
[Music]
so you you know it's my last week on the
job and i think
[Music]
what did he say you know it's my last
week on the job and i think this would
happen
[Music]
i think she got bumped and her whole
body got bumped everywhere just a whole
big old bump
just lasting four months
but this is live tv and everything's
okay
no cutaway man i love the i love that
they just they keep it on her
capture the moment
you think when she got hit here they'd
be like all right well we'll check back
and win with her
like at least a little bit of like oh my
god are you okay oh my god he's just
like huh
no reaction
oh
our on-field reporter
appears to have been hitting by a car
yeah and i guess
he didn't have a video feed so he was
just hearing it but i don't know
it
i don't think you need to
see it to be able to react a little bit
more than that
what is this comment abe was that meant
for me
not just what dan basically just said
about uh oh he couldn't see her
i'll stop why is phil you got to ruin
the phone philly d said he couldn't see
her philly just stop
stop j you didn't have to say that
i don't think it matters really
well oh it's yeah she literally says i
was just hit by a car and it's like
right
regardless if you see it or not you know
if you're on the phone with somebody you
would be kind of shocked to hear that oh
wow
i'm talking to dan hey so yeah we're
finishing prep for the episode
i just got hit by a car
oh
anyway
[Laughter]
[Music]
well she's a trooper anyway
i love she says it's okay i got hit by a
car before yeah this ain't my first
rodeo
i think she probably got hurt
from that
yeah she's in shock
i love his concern man he's awesome
well there you go
oh wow that's what's happening huh
all right this is what i've been looking
for oh
caller isaac sounds really pro okay we
have a caller
we got a caller huh let me check over
the calls we've got something good
um
um
oh wow
i got a few people i want to talk to
here
oh this guy's from my
town spending time in ventura i don't
know bro
let's talk to you so isaac here
this sounds interesting
isaac had a run-in with our good friend
gary vee garyvee and friends
prolific
crypto uh i don't want to say scammer
but uh
hey how's it going how do you how do you
call some yeah
maybe more of a cult leader how what do
you call someone who convinces morons to
part with millions of dollars willingly
for something that's worthless
a marketing genius
oh
fair
hey uh hey isaac what's going on
hey how's it going
how's it going well i just want to say
i'm a member of the tribe as well
love you guys you know ethan it sucks
you're famous because i i think we'd be
friends um but i'm appreciative for your
entertainment damn that sucks it sucks
sucks you're famous dude
i'll give it all i give it all up to be
friends with you isaac
well thank you thank you we would have
been what do you mean you're a member of
the tribe that you're jewish
yeah i'm jewish i'm jewish
do you think that contributes to me that
we could be good friends because we're
both jewish
that's actually the only reason yeah i
feel that something else
sometimes that's enough no i think
yeah no i'm just kidding there's a we
have a lot in common but anyway so we
were uh we
went uh went to a basketball game we
were sitting courtside at madison square
garden and uh
garyvee it's a you know it's a humble
brag but wait hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on your court side
yeah
what do you do for a little bit we
record that what do you do
it was so it was my i know it sounds
like a humble brag but it was it was my
dad's gift to himself for his retirement
oh okay so kicking cancer
oh that's good for your dad
so you know he treated my girlfriend and
i and my sister so the four of us went
so okay so it was a it was a it was a
kind of a one-time
lifetime experience celebration
well yeah i mean you know we could you
know it would be nice to do it again but
uh yeah it was it was good okay one time
ago well very good i'm glad your dad's
doing well
the point is the point is we don't go
every week i think that's what we're
saying we don't go every week you know
we we could hopefully go again in the
future but yeah we haven't done it
before so anyway so we were sitting
there you know it was exhilarating uh
you know we there was like celebrity
role bro so there was like you know
kevin bacon ellen pompeo trevor noah
spike lee you know like big celebrities
were sitting there
and you know i don't have like this you
know groundbreaking story but like gary
vee was there and the only reason i saw
him like actually notice him was you
know all the other celebrities like
michael rappaport i sent the image
i took a selfie with like wearing all
black black cap you know kind of like
incognito you know how you know like
celebrities usually do like you know how
you walk around with you know glasses on
and everything um just kidding but he so
garyvee was wearing an orange jacket
like bright orange and a backwards cap
and the only reason i noticed him he was
sitting like right behind celebrity row
like they called it and uh
he was waving like in the video i sent
he was waving at like people and like
like trying to flag down a friend but
like he was instead of just texting his
friend like hey i'm sitting here he's
standing up waving and then other people
are like waving at him and he's like
just like making weights
oh we have video no way we have the
video oh this is
yes so so let me get this straight he's
not in the celebrity section he got the
tickets he's sitting behind it that's
awesome
he was part of it so he bought tickets
close to the celebrity section to make
it seem like he's in the celebrity
section then he stands up and starts
waving around so people
to make it seem like a video he's waving
around like probably trying to flag down
a friend but he's throwing up the peace
sign for so long
it's like ridiculous
and
so then so you know like and also you
know at the end of the game or like
during so during uh half time we went to
like the uh like i don't know it's like
the vip lounge whatever it is like free
food and stuff and like you know uh
michael raptor is there and he's just
kind of standing by himself like michael
rappaport would go to the lounge for
free food
yeah exactly that that's the reason he
was there but anyway like garyvee is
just trying to make a bigger deal than
it is but after the game i'm like trying
to take a picture with real celebrities
and he's walking around as you see a
picture i sent it on the court and he
comes up to me and says hey do you want
a photo with me i swear to god
i said yeah
i said yes because you know let me give
him the benefit of the doubt he's being
nice and like
why would you go up to a random person
did maybe because i'm standing there
with a phone and he goes hey do you want
do you want a photo can i not like and
even my girlfriend's standing there like
who is this and i'm just like oh it's
garyvee like at this like like i'm
nervous it's garyvee asking everyone if
he wants a photo
it's like can i exactly and you know i'm
giving him the benefit of doubt is that
you know if if i wanted a picture with
him instead of me asking he's trying to
be nice but it's just like no celebrity
like no one else was doing that there it
was very weird like is it is it possible
that
you were staring at him because you were
so amused by the spectacle and he
thought you were a fan like eagerly but
too shy to ask for a photo could be or
videotaping no no it it would be that if
i was staring at him like holy [ __ ]
scary it was like he walked by we made
eye contact but he's walking on the
court he's the only celebrity guy like
like going like on the court after the
game to like obviously he took photos of
a ton of people like he's like walking
around like trying to get himself
noticed but like also it's it was it's
more exciting to see celebrities when
they're like kind of hard to reach and
reserve like you have to go up to them
and it's just like this weird balance
where he's just on the wrong side of the
scale like you know i looked in his
direction and he asked me hey you want a
photo and like in his voice hey you want
a photo like hey you want a phone
hey my dad's here you want to make out
yeah
wait did you wait did you take wait hold
on hold on hold on hold on
wait hang on did you
take this video
yeah i i took that thing oh this is a
good video
he sent these i thought you guys pulled
this from the internet or not no no no
yeah no no no i i i took i took way more
videos oh so he was he was actually too
far away from you i think to realize
that you were
wait was he giving you the peace sign
no that's what it looks like he actually
i don't know if uh cam showed you the
photo but i took a spill of him just
staring why it looks like he's looking
at me but he's just like he's just
staring he's standing and staring
and yeah and it's right so he's like one
row behind celebrity row and all the
other stuff like look at him giving the
peace sign it's so weird
you're right it's it's attention seeking
behavior he's looking for validation big
time
and and then if you see in the video
like other people kind of throw up the
peace on because it's just like you know
you wave behind somebody other people
are going to wave too but look at that
stare look at that dome
and also did you see he has a new nfc
restaurant where you need his nfcs to
join and eat at his club oh god no i'm
telling you i i don't i get bad vibes
from gary vee
no it was oh wow wait how tall is he
wait hold on
sorry to keep doing this this height
this height uh gating but how tall is he
you got intel on that dan i'm looking it
up uh
no not gary valenciana five seven five
seven that's not bad
i guess he's just on a he's on the court
and everyone there's tall as hell can
you just cruise around on the court what
is this
like what's the rule what's the
etiquette he's not even in the celebrity
section well after the game but
yeah
like you said i mean he's not even
actually courtside so dude is literally
not even in the celeb section
it's awesome that's a great one
there you go
are you still with this isaac or it
looks like you dropped actually oh
well shout out to isaac yeah that's
awesome thanks for bringing this to us
garyvee
my name is gary me
i want to do that i want to sit right by
the celebrity section
because you know if you have any
notoriety at all you're in a stadium
with what like 30 000 plus people you're
going to stand up and give out peace
outs and if you're wearing an orange
hoodie people are going to notice you
oh they look you know shout out
everybody
it's just it's a little cringe isn't it
a little bit yeah here i found what he's
talking about nft restaurant opening in
new york
status with a side of seafood once a day
genuinely sit there for five minutes and
make pretend one of them got shot in the
face that's my trick to happiness folks
that's what he was doing to that
pretending to shoot him in the face
what is this restaurant he's doing
i just found the article uh let me uh
i can't wait for the nft market to
[ __ ] implode i think it's in the
process and then doing it and then he's
going to move on to the next scam the
next scam yeah
he's like well anyway i made like
i made like a hundred million dollars so
anyway have you guys heard about this
new thing called uh hollow uh
have you guys heard about this new thing
they're like holograms that you keep on
a rock it's gonna change the [ __ ]
universe
wait i are you referencing the guy that
was getting roasted on twitter for
making a
a physical nft that was just a hologram
no that is not the best that's the best
it's a circle he made a physical nft yes
you guys they're making physical nfts
now do you know what that means
i don't
but it doesn't make any [ __ ] sense i
cracked up when i saw this uh
i try to think but nothing happens
yeah i bet you once the nft economy is
totally collapsed gary v is going to
pretend like it never happened
i basically turn an nft into an animated
physical object without using a screen
cables or electricity i'll be doing a
lot more of these it's literally just
like a [ __ ] yo
like when we were kids yo let me frame
that and put it on my wall
that's sick it's like a real physical
piece of art
that's fire
also and this is new technology
it's not just like
a piece of plastic with some layers
that's existed for like 50 years this is
so good
yo this guy is true i love how he tries
to hype up like it's some crazy
technology
and do you ship it on pokemon cards for
like 30 years right
i'm skimming the uh
i was giving this article about his
restaurant and apparently it sounds like
it's just that you have to own some nft
to be able to get into the restaurant
okay why do i care is it free food or
some [ __ ] well it just seems like it's
just like a it's just a membership it's
just a club that's the thing is like
all of this nft stuff and not just most
implementations of like this block
change [ __ ]
like can anybody
point to one that isn't just something
that's always existed but shittier
like this is just this is a country club
this is buying a membership to a country
club but now it's on the blockchain but
it's shittier right right like you go to
a re that's by the way that restaurant
is not sustainable business
you can't serve people that just own
kryptos i guess you can if you're gary
vee made a hundred million dollars
selling dumb ass i mean it's something
like thing in manhattan so you know
they're gonna have to pay for it anyways
no oh definitely yeah oh yeah no it's
not free once you get in it's just it's
just you have to pay a lot of money to
even well be able to access it as a wise
man once said i would never want to be a
member of a club that would have me as a
member
right
so count me out
who was that was that groucho yes it was
okay
great saying yeah so true also
oh so this attention-seeking behavior
extent this is a b
a b sent me this are you going against
the garyvee family
no but you know you always got my
loyalty
you think
you come first so in the dark knight
situation where you had to kill one save
one all right kill gary thank you say it
again
say it again but louder i would unalive
gary
you hear that game terrible maybe
maybe you stand up please stand up baby
um
here's more attention grabbing behavior
uh by gary vayner would stand out just
moments ago i was on sportscenter they
were showing a ridiculous highlight that
serendipitously happened near me
and then i
you know celebrate i'm sure we're
chopping it in right now
dude you're such an attention seeker
and they made a reference to me which
then got a lot of people who follow me
to mention me on social i engaged with
them this my friends is what's called
classic attention oh my god wait wait
whoa whoa wearing an ugly sweater
courtside at the knicks game and hacking
attention he's hacking this is social
engineering wearing obnoxious clothing
cord side by the way it's not that
[ __ ] easy to hack people's attention
when you don't have like twenty thousand
dollars to blow on a courtside seat
which is like all of the advice he gives
is like well if you have ten million
dollars this should this tip is really
gonna help you out
abe
i still like them
okay just checking
what an [ __ ] i love this
if you're an obnoxious piece of [ __ ]
people are gonna notice you
does it really work though if you're not
already famous because he says people
shared it because it was me
yeah so you're just going to be an
obnoxious you're telling people to be an
obnoxious [ __ ]
right understanding what you need to do
not only digitally
or by being in the community 90 times
two cents at a time but also
understanding in real life you know
whether it's your speaking style and
it's not about being provocative or
ridiculous for the sake of being
ridiculous you need to be authentic to
yourself right and so it's not a mohawk
or a big hat it's like i can wear some
sweaters i can do that i'm comfortable
with that so it's not forcing it because
lack of authenticity is the
vulnerability at the macro of this whole
game can you please shut the [ __ ] up
then
vulnerability of authenticity is the
macro at this whole game
hey garyvee do me a [ __ ] favor just
take a vacation okay
with all your nft money
go to the vineyard and make out with
your dad
i don't want to see you anymore that was
just another attention
tactic right there
i think it might have been yeah okay
i've been waiting to talk about this i'm
very excited tim poole this is kind of
old
stale tea
it's kind of room temperature at this
moment but it's still good
this was in response to oh me calling
joe rogan unhealthy
right i didn't talk about it on the show
it happened over the break
i made some jokes about joe rogan
uh
he's not healthy what can i say the dude
is jacked with
he's he's full up on
steroids human growth hormone he
literally eats only meat
red meat
he eats red no he's not on that diet is
he he just recently announced he's gonna
eat only red meat and doing the jordan
peterson diet yeah oh he's doing fruit
yeah he's adding fruit to the mix okay
at least that i guess
that gets my dick hard
yeah i mean that all meat diet didn't go
so well for for old jp no he he still
stands by it even though he had like a
thimble of apple cider and had a thyroid
overwhelming sense of doom
that's awesome
i think it scrambled his brain because
ever since he had that sip of that
thimble of apple cider things have been
just
i don't know he seems lost to the world
anyway tim poole of course everyone all
the conservatives are simping and
defending joe rogan's honor it's
important to talk about you so this was
uh here we go tim pool everybody
tuber ethan klein calls joe rogan a
piece of ish for vaccine misinformation
rogan's fan hit back after klein calls
out how podcasters logic makes no sense
i appreciate you bringing back ish by
the way well luke did it now by the way
this guy
nick what's his name nick fuentes or is
that someone else well who's this guy
he's another like i would be shocked if
nick fuentes was on the show
this guy is just as bad i mean yeah i
don't think i don't think it's him
the fuentes is the little white
nationalist guy that picks his nose
until it bleeds
right yeah
right not nick flint is
his favorite word
i can't say much here it's deserve it's
deserves my vocabulary has been cut in
like deserves
who lives on elk meat egg yolk and human
growth hormone with lungs full of tar
thinks he's healthier than everyone
this mf or shabby that when he got
covered he threw the kitchen sink at it
if you're so healthy just write it out
like you say a man should do this cause
so much vaccine hesitancy and
misinformation and he doesn't even have
the balls to stand by the issue preaches
now he's on his show talking about are
you really not saying [ __ ] you giant
[ __ ] you stupid [ __ ] you know
what i shouldn't even say [ __ ] that's
derogatory towards women
i'm gonna start
phasing that out they're really just
um
cowards they're turret you know flaming
turd bag
is saying is avoiding saying curse words
naughty words uh an alpha move i don't
think so
it seems weak
it's a baby should just die of covet due
to such an effing piece of s
um
is i mean i i wait does i have a
legitimate question it's not a dig is
ethan klein saying this because he's an
unhealthy overweight individual it's
important to talk about again they i
love that so so he here they go
his logic makes no sense
and then instead of addressing why my
logic makes no sense they go is he just
saying this because he's fat
so like it was like when joe rogan was
talking about being overweight and
unhealthy was bad for you
i think people yeah people take it
personally so if you understand
so okay first of all tim poole is a
[ __ ] such a stupid analysis
i know i'm fat i know i'm overweight why
don't you talk about what i said
but then his homie comes in here with
the really dumb [ __ ] here if you
understand um
uh
sociosexual hierarchy right this is
typical red flag any women who ser
dude if you ever encounter a dude
[ __ ] sexual sociosexual hierarchy
abort abort abort these men are black
built
[Music]
these men hate their moms they hate
themselves
you kind of have to be a psychopath to
believe in this [ __ ]
h against the alpha male right this is
the basic idea of you know someone who's
kind of at the bottom of the food chain
in in terms of preference
lashing out at someone who is higher up
on the food chain from them and it's
it's very simple you see this a lot
with youtubers but not just youtubers in
general that's just they're more
ubiquitous these days um you see it
everywhere you see it in real life you
see it in you know
office hierarchy you see it in high
schools colleges political leadership
that's when it's scary to an extent oh
yeah political leadership is a little
bit different though because isn't
is not
conducted because just because of
someone's um you know health and prowess
and and accomplishment right there's all
these like byzantine rules and ways let
me look at you know we've got like the
peter like the
peter and i want to play this again
because i was talking over the first
part when joe rogan was talking about
being overweight and unhealthy was bad
for you
i think people yeah people take it
personally so if you understand if you
understand um
uh
sociosexual hierarchy right this is
typical gamma male rage against an alpha
male gamma member so so me criticizing
joe rogan spreading covet misinformation
is gamma male rage which i didn't know
what a gamma male was but apparently
it's even is it gamma male it's even
lower than a beta or it's higher than a
beta
i think it's in most cases lower but
i'm not kidding when
you go to like when you just type gamma
mail and it comes up with all these
articles from [ __ ] like the adultman.com
red pillar
men men
men's xp.com
they
have
radically different definitions of what
a gamma male is well i know it's bad
well here listen this one gamma male
personality qualities adventurous
fun-loving and restless but that's one
so some of them think gammas are good
some of them think gammas are bad right
he's talking about the bad gammas okay
so i mean here let me click a different
one let's see what this gamma says gamma
means i mean left intellectual romantic
man who struggles with women and suffers
from chronic nice guy syndrome
i mean that doesn't really sound like
ethan
i mean well i've been married for like
[ __ ] 10 years and i'm about to have
my second child i don't think
it's almost like
none of this is really based in anything
i mean it's based in their own
insecurity that's the only thing it's
based on i mean this whole alpha male
thing all started
i believe because of like one study 30
years ago
about
hierarchies in in wolves and it was
completely discredited because the study
was based on wolves in captivity and
their behavior in the wild doesn't
actually follow this whole like alpha
thing
anyways so it's all based on also um
they're not wolves right exactly so
structures are a little more complicated
in a very specific circumstance that has
been widely discredited are there gamma
walls
i think if there's alpha water they're
beta i don't know
and they just keep stacking them like
the wolves
well see this hierarchy doesn't even
show the sigma we just got alpha beta
delta gamma omega well anyway his hobie
here is saying that i have gamma male
rage against alphas like joe rogan by
the way
who literally
is joe rogan and alpha i mean dude what
are we talking about here i'm not
somebody in the chat said it's astrology
for in cells
that's astrology for insults i mean joe
joe rogan's like 5'3
the dude is so insecure his nipples are
like the size of the eiffel tower
because
he pumps himself so full of human growth
hormone testosterone because he can't
handle the the thought of aging
appropriately
nobel prize yeah i mean
he he yeah i mean his blood his blood
might have more alpha brain in it than
actual like red blood cells but that
doesn't make him alpha that just means
he's taking a bunch of weird supplements
ooh somebody just did a five dollar
super chat that said epsilon ethon
epsilon ethan is epsilon male 1 what's
that epsilon male is that a real thing
it is now
all you have to do is speak it into
existence ada ila delta dan lambda love
iota ian zeta zack and omega olivia zeta
sounds bad zack because that's like the
all the way down at z no it means he's a
zetty a
zaddy
that ain't bad that's good [ __ ]
i'm about to tear you up like a bowl of
brown eminem's boy
zing it on dude
um it's too hot in here now
bro that's so gamma of you all right i
got it
so so let me make this straight because
like otherwise i mean if we're talking
about social sexual hierarchy i
have i'm like have a good job right
i have a wife that i've been in a loving
relationship with i have i have a family
so i'm fat basically does being fat make
me a beta or gamma
well also like
publicly calling out another person
with a huge platform a bigger one than
your own and going in on them
i mean
again i don't think any of this is real
anyways but can you argue that that is
alpha energy like you're not backing
down like if you were like submissive
you would just like i mean what's beta
is all of these people who go on joe
rogan's show and just submissive
right so submissive to joe right never
ever ever do it never be well yeah you
never be a beta being a beta is death
never be a beta which i hate even like
framing it like that because again the
whole premise is so [ __ ] stupid of
course i'm just trying i'm trying it's
like even within their own exact world
view
i i don't really see how it's gamma but
his theory is that i'm angry because of
all the [ __ ] joe's getting
right joe is such an alpha and he gets
so much [ __ ] so much female or woman's
attention that i'm just bitterly jealous
of my gamma rage
yeah i guess yeah this guy's name is
jack prosiak he's also like a psycho oh
i know that name i recognize give me
some factoids about him
someone who's kind of at the bottom of
the prolapse
in in terms of but again my favorite
part of this without knowing anything
about me
he doesn't engage with my statement at
all he is completely sidestepping
what i think is a totally valid correct
point which is that joe rogan and an
ultimate beta move after preaching about
masculinity and just you know not
getting vaccinated and all this [ __ ]
instead of just riding out the virus
like he should do like he preaches he
should do he literally has a doctor on
call to give him experimental drugs and
every freaking drug under the sun to
treat it that's beta energy bro
submissive
you know just take the vaccine at that
point you beta ass
oh yeah he works for o-n-n o-a-n-n jack
apparently he had something to do with
the charlottesville rally and stuff too
who's been embraced by president trump
of course he has collaborated for years
with white supremacists neo-fascists and
anti-semites a hate watch investigation
has determined so
by the way super quality guest there uh
tim poole
well that's just the mainstream media
that's uh you know
um
uh smearing his good name fake news uh
he was also a pizzagate guy
uh
right oann
uh far right cable news network turning
point usa
so yeah i mean you know typical you get
the idea yeah
these guys are all virgins by the way
like let's be honest all these turning
point usa guys all these tiny faced
white supremacists
yeah he ran a game of thrones blog for a
while he did yeah that's the coolest
thing about him yeah it's called
angrygameofthronesfan.com
what what
interesting hobby there buddy
i mean some alpha [ __ ] right there
blogging blogging about uh fantasy shows
on
beta energy is he married is he in a
relationship tell me tell me this this
uh
tell me about this alpha male as he is
he is successfully mated with a female
uh
i mean he doesn't have a wife listed on
his oh my god dude you're not even mad
you haven't even successfully made it oh
no he doesn't he was married oh here's a
beautiful picture of them together
hold on this is this is what comes up
just doing a little white power assembly
white power white power
that's a good guy tim paul
are you comfortable having people who
flash white power signs when
photographed well he's he is in gay he's
married
that's good lady macbeth over there
looks like he even has a kid so okay so
he's so he's up there he's got the proof
sexual sexual hierarchy he might be
above alpha he's he's transcended
black power
cool guy
yeah i love it
tim poole what is wrong with you bro you
literally have people who flash white
power signs and then act like you're
just some dude you're just sitting
across from a dude who actively flashes
white power when photographed with his
family and you're like yeah this guy has
legitimate views about sexual social
hierarchy and that's what we're going to
talk
about and i'm going to get it
not pick because he's our most competent
leader right um that's not exactly how
he got there so for ethan klein to lash
out it's totally in line if you
understand okay do you want to talk
about what i said at all
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're talking about
astrology dude do you want to talk was
mercury in retrograde or what's the bro
version of that was uh
was the alpha pack circling yeah
was the alpha pack was the alphabet made
in january
i like
cam's little comment on that instagram
post that says a gaggle of
a gaggle of gammas gaggle gamble males
gossiping
well stated cam grants biosexual
hierarchy that being said my question is
he says lungs full of tar is is derwick
and a smoker
yes geniuses he lit
he smokes in every episode
uh yeah well he smokes cigars which you
technically don't inhale but he also
dropped the weed yeah exactly so yeah
that definitely puts starring by the way
smoking cigars is not a healthy activity
right i don't know if he was maybe
trying to be
smoking so get a small gotcha on that or
something he smokes weed that's what i
was talking about right yeah but thanks
for bringing up that he also smoked
cigars yeah right
he didn't understand weed right yeah
he didn't smoke cigarettes but
does he i don't think
cigars pops on oh that's right that's
right i'm pretty sure you guys know
there's tar and weed right cigarettes
but does he inhale he's a healthy guy i
don't know you don't really you're not
supposed to inhale yeah obviously so how
would your lungs be filled with tar you
just said he smokes weed
you [ __ ] morons
but we should also point out that this
is some of the stupidest advice given
out by ethan klein that absolutely makes
no sense you're telling joe rogan not to
take medicine that a doctor is telling
him to take this is the paradox of what
he said ethan kline is not a medical
doctor a doctor oh my [ __ ] these people
are you just so
that he shouldn't take it no i was
speaking rhetorically because i was like
if you're such a man
right and you're telling people not to
get vaccinated and just ride that out
because because it's like apparently not
dangerous
then why did you get all this treatment
i didn't say don't get treated
they're they're are they dumb so dumb
are they honestly just misrepresenting
this to keep the propaganda going z
right now joe biden was not picked
because he's our most competent leader
right yeah it's crazy man these people
are just dumb as hell look straight up
pretty interesting right
jordan peterson's going on uh
jordan peterson
is going on joe rogan what's his [ __ ]
going to the oscars
is this for real why are you dressed
like that why are you dressed like a
waiter
oh my god he is just
this is going to be an unhinged one i
have a feeling
so he's going on joe rogan today both
just real quick i'm seeing a bunch of
people in the chat saying weed doesn't
put tar in your lungs yes it does guys
google that is just please don't look it
up i don't know i don't know what you're
talking about yeah i'm not doing this
marijuana
uh is a miracle drug that has no
consequences at all a little propaganda
and somebody who smokes weed all the
time there is definitely
i mean if you're smoking butt if you're
if you're burning flour
it is if you are inhaling smoke yes you
are putting tar in your lungs you are
damaging your lungs just be straight up
look it's probably less harmful than you
know yeah probably than cigarettes
because it's cigarettes are so processed
with all this crap if you've ever smoked
in out of a a glass piece
uh like a pipe or a bong or anything you
know like the resin you know all that
stuff that like builds up around the
bowl that's in your lungs that's going
in your life go go go take a dog go
smoke a joint or whatever and blow it
through a t-shirt right see what happens
guys this is i'm so sick
of weed smokers acting like it's some
miracle drug that just like
magically goes through your body okay
wait what the [ __ ] what is this you
google it dan it doesn't oh my god yeah
edibles
edibles obviously
what
these people are still saying that i'm
wrong not that you need to google it but
if you google is their tar and we it's
literally the first thing that comes up
that they're similar to tobacco just go
blow weed smoke through a shirt you guys
are seeing what i'm looking for like
hassan right now
i'm not sick guys i'm not saying don't
smoke it's fine do whatever you want i'm
not saying don't do it but just be real
about what it's doing exactly i grew up
around all this propaganda that like
weed is like this miracle drug it's
perfect it doesn't harm your health it's
good for your mental health and i'm
sorry but i think the the dangers of
weed is
so understated now there's nothing wrong
some people love it it's medicinal it's
recreational and all these good things
that i that i'm totally down with but
guys let's be real
okay
you could get a vape right yeah i mean
i've heard that wheat has even more tar
than uh
cigarettes because you smoke more of it
well and it's not filtered i mean if you
if you smoke cigarettes it's going
through a cotton filter that is
absorbing a decent amount of tar if
you're smoking joints or blunts or
something it's going well i mean once
wrapped in tobacco so people are saying
there's no tar someone said because of
how typical i'm sorry because how it is
typically smoked marijuana smoking leads
to four times the uh
four times the amount of tar company
exactly it has more tar
so you guys let's be real come on smoke
weed but but be aware of what you're
doing at least
smoke weed every day
so yes joe's rogan's lungs are full of
time
also i think joe rogan might be an
alcoholic after i saw his recent
appearance on kill tonight my video was
so [ __ ] funny
if you're 50 years old and getting that
trashed out in public you might be an
alcoholic
and he drinks every day like it seems
like he's drinking on his drink on the
show i i don't i don't know
he might not not healthy
just saying
well certainly drinking alcohol isn't
healthy yeah drinking every day
not a healthy activity
might come as it comes as a surprise to
all the alphas out there
just saying
just saying just saying so yeah anyway
uh uh
jordan peterson cosplaying as an usher
for the uh what this is bad bro he's
usually well dressed in his suits but i
don't like this
what's with the talks dude
let's see that's how you know he's gone
full uh
right wing when the bow tie comes out
right
the tucker the tucker bow
that's true somebody said well if i
don't drink then how will i cure my
depression three sips just that well you
won't you don't have to drink a lot you
just need three sips yeah don't go crazy
yeah and it could just be beer you
proved it
[Laughter]
um so what i'm wondering is he's going
on joe rogan we both we ha i had a very
public
twitter
uh entanglement with both of them
there's a good chance they're going to
talk about me
i feel like i yeah i've had that feeling
too i'm waiting to watch it it's fine i
haven't even considered that well
here's okay
i'll make a prediction jordan peterson
will bring you up and joe rogan will act
like he has no idea who you are
you think so he follows me on twitter
we've talked in the dm's of slightly joe
rogan yeah a long time ago it was
something about when out when we were
i'm not saying he doesn't know who you
are i'm saying are going to be like who
who's this right
okay
i hope they don't i don't need any [ __ ]
from their the psychologist all right i
don't need
well have you heard about this ethan
klein character he tried canceling me
i by the way do you hear that he
self-cancelled
he quit uh
his university job yeah when's the last
time he stepped in a classroom
i have no idea he's been on a hospital
bed for the past year
from one draw i had a drop of apple
cider
i'm still recovering
[Music]
but um
jordan's gonna this thing this is the
new thing on the right any mild amount
of criticism he's cancelling me
bro i don't give a [ __ ] what anyone else
does i didn't want you on my channel you
got to decide do i have ownership of my
property or am i a trouncing free speech
there's literally people saying i'm sent
it's censorship it's my [ __ ] show
yeah that's a weird [ __ ] take it's my
show when you when you talked about this
on your uh on your on the ethan klein
channel which by the way big big fan of
the name change thank you we're back to
being the only h3 tv on the platform
well done well done
but yeah um
i watched
the video where you were talking about
this whole situation and everything and
uh yeah that is
gotta be one of the worst censorship set
your sense it's your own show it's my
[ __ ] show
it's your property so stupid
censorship and then well there was a
tweet that's like wow censorship nice
job and i had like you know an insane
amount of likes so it's actually
these people are not they're not bright
yeah
so
i think jordan peter's gonna be like
this guy canceled me on twitter named
ethan klein
he erased two of my episodes
and i owned him
i told him watch out for cancel culture
bosco
yeah what was the own
because he said underneath
to
be careful about appeasing the mob
because soon they'll come after you and
you will never be able to appease them
what an own
yeah and then well he asked me for
specific reasons i provided them and he
did not respond
[Music]
i provided for explicit incident
incidents that i thought
were disgusting takes on his part he
didn't address it
so who's debating out
he straight ducked me okay
yeah but he's gonna go cry about how i
canceled him by um taking ownership of
my own property let's see
yeah i actually hope they don't because
i don't need that [ __ ] especially
when he was about to give birth these
people are literally psychotic
yeah yeah i guess we could do without
that ethan klein
who lives in bel air
at this zip code and this community
tried to cancel me
[Music]
a [ __ ] dozer
just eating m m's
yeah and the chad's not happy about it
because you're chewing into the mic just
just saying i'm moving the mic
can i get some of those
oh i almost caught it
one more
jesus you're gonna tear the whole
scorpion apart
come on
you know what we should stop doing we
should stop because the dogs yeah the
dogs are gonna come in and eat
just just one just
wait don't don't grab just let it come
to you
stick your finger
all right nobody tell me you throw it to
me i'll give it to him why don't i just
come over there and grab him instead of
instead of
doing that why don't you throw it to me
and i'll give it to him
all right i'm throwing baby
i got it nice first try
beautiful wow you got one m m what's on
one
guys do you think i'm a gamma male an
alpha male a beta male or sigma can we
take a poll
um well there's only four options yeah
um
well there's so many more types of males
than just the four well those are the
ones that have been floated and so well
what's nobody's floated alpha let's be
honest what sort of male is ethan alpha
alpha sigma
sigma gamma
or beta
beta
wait why aren't we putting
yeah beta's got to be in here [ __ ] the
sigma no it did they're both in there no
alpha sigma gamma and delta no not delta
there's no doubt
there is delta don't include delta okay
beta sigma alpha gamma
don't let me down
i won't be able to live with myself
if i don't get what i want
what do you want
i need their
oh baby i'm an alpha what are you was
that what you were hoping for
just oh no i have 20 beta i wasn't
hoping for anything particular
show this because we all determined that
we were
this is a group of sigmas
yes sigma falling out of favor i noticed
a lot of them don't even reference sigma
anymore
i'm a ligma uh
yeah
well it looks like alpha but just by a
hair stigma not a hair that's a that's a
resounding victory bro don't take that
away from me okay i'm straight alpha
mailing it up sweet
congratulations
sick
damn dude all right let's do do we have
two more ads at the time i sure do so
let's do this we'll come back and do the
fresh and fit podcast these guys are
terrible freaks they are just such
[ __ ] they oh this is actually from
their description they describe
themselves as the world's number one
men's podcast we provide the truth to
females fitness and finance
that's their words
verbatim
they've had a whole slew of
women come on their show and they just
are horrible
say horrible things and actually they've
been getting owned by them too i don't
know why this show's even popular but
we'll get into that let's thank our
sponsors first
mint mobile
we love
uh mint mobile
saving more spending less is one of your
top goals for 2022. amy can it why is it
going to be like all or nothing with the
ac
aren't there layers
uh i'll get right on that thank you bro
no problem
like there's got to be something there's
got to be something between full blast
and all completely off i'm literally
just heading on and off i need green m
m's only i need brown m m's only i need
all my eminence separated yes it was
don't pretend like you didn't i think
now that you know you're on alpha you're
kind of just i'm like
dude no but like come on i don't
i'm freezing i'm freezing my ass off
you're wearing shorts in january i uh
look just set it to a nice degree it's
all it can't be all on and all up i'm
sitting in front of lights it's hot all
right fair enough
you know
set to like 40 degrees
oh did i mention mint mobile
[Laughter]
if saving more and spending less is one
of your top goals for 2022 why are you
still paying insane's amounts of money
every month for wireless switching to
mint mobile is the easiest way to save
this year and as the first company to
sell premium wireless service only
online mipmobile lets you maximize your
savings with plans
starting at just 15 a month
dantome it's only 15 a month well it
starts with you love it though but i do
love it it's uh the service is great
it's just as good as
the big guys same [ __ ] same same [ __ ]
better price different name better price
simple as that for people looking for
extra savings this year mint mobile
offers premium wireless for just 15
bucks a month and by going online only
eliminating traditional cost of retail
mint mobile passes significant savings
on to you all plants come with unlimited
talk and text plus high speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan and keep your same phone
number along with all your existing
contacts with mint mobile choose the
amount of monthly data that's right for
you and stop paying for data that you
never dang use switch to mit mobile and
get premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plane shipped to your door
for free go to mobile.com h3tv that's
mintmobile.com h3tv thank you thank you
[Music]
and finally thank you to honey
yes we love honey man
i love this song too this is the honey
song every time let's meet him
it's a bomb it is such a bottle
and it is good it makes sense because
honey is a bop too
today's episode sponsored by honey the
easy way to save when shopping on your
iphone or computer oh did they add it on
iphone
that's new i think because it usually
was only on computer true
shopping online is great i mean let's
face it the majority of us shop online
but with honey
it makes shopping even better you know
there's infinite codes out there while
honey scours the internet for the best
code possible and automatically applies
it to checkout it's free it's easy to
stall it's a no-brainer it saves me so
much money is this something you'll send
you yes it is yeah i mean i don't know
what you bought a couch i think i think
it was a couch yeah yeah we bought a
couch for the basement look at that ela
didn't even try she was about to buy it
for the full price and honey swooped in
and saved us 400 freaking bucks
insane
[ __ ] it is it's insane
oh
just it's just insane
oh my god imagine you're shopping one of
your favorite sites when you check out
the honey button appears and all you
have to do is click apply coupon wait a
few seconds honey searches for coupons
they can find for that site and if honey
finds a coupon you'll watch the price
drop magically watch it drop instantly
um
they're on all all websites basically
pretty much you got clothing electronics
shopping pretty much of any variety
it's gonna it's gonna make shopping so
much better for you honey doesn't just
work on the desktop now it works on the
iphone yeah
just activate it on safari in your phone
uh and
your phone and save on the go if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing out and by getting
it you're doing yourself a solid and
supporting the show i'd never recommend
something i don't use i use honey on all
my browsers i love it get honey for free
at
jointhoney.comtv that's join honey.com
h3tv
all right thank you ethan real quick i
have breaking gabe news
uh i just got a text from nick that they
granted him a hundred thousand followers
back on his tick tock account huh
what does that mean
like they took three hundred thousand
away they gave a hundred thousand back
yeah
so confusing why are they messing with
them i don't know but one step in the
right direction well
free game guys pre-game we absolutely
need to free gabe they really like that
peeing my [ __ ] thing
that really worked they were so pickled
by that
tick tock was loving the new
direction of his of his account
come on that shit's funny you guys
stock market's been a wild ride this
week man last week would it go down like
10 or something by now
oh i haven't really been watching that
closely
i know it's heading down i just reinvest
them down what happened maybe you lose
money because you rebought i'm yep i
bought i think three ethereum i've lost
almost 40 percent if not more are you 40
it went down since you bought it
i think i'm whoa i'm still up from when
we did all the stupid nfts we got 1800
it was worth when we got it i think it's
going to end up being because i from the
get-go i've been holding on to it for a
year because if you hold for a year then
it you get taxed at a lower rate right
is it a year or two years it's a year
okay capital gains what just one year
yeah just one year baby i thought it was
two
well [ __ ]
well maybe two that would give me more
time
anyways uh
so i that was always one year yeah that
was always the move it was for me was to
just get rid of it as soon as i could oh
you're just waiting yeah but then now
it's it's crashing i i think it'll be a
year in like another month or two so
let's just hold it in 12 months i mean
chances are it's going to bounce back up
or it'll go to zero maybe basically
those are the two outcomes
i also bought back in i uh
i took a hit too i should have known
when zack bought it and i should have
known i [ __ ] up i was like
with peace and love
[Laughter]
like a month after that whole meal
by the way ethereum is down 40 percent
this month that is
whoa yeah but guys look on the bright
side the in the year ethereum is up 95
yeah see there you go so that's kind of
great when we got the ethereum it was
worth 1800 it's still at 2400 which is i
think it was wasn't it like 1400 when i
got no it was 18 i remember yeah right
because you got rid of it immediately
right
i sold immediately yeah yeah yeah
well i guess i could have waited a year
that would have been smart i sold that
[ __ ] because i was like this going to
zero i thought for sure i was like this
is a hot potato it's going nothing
this [ __ ] is worthless
but i was wrong
uh but what did you buy it at ab because
it's at 20 basically 2415 right now i
bought them around 3 000.
oof
yeah and how long ago was that
uh
honestly i don't even remember to be
honest it was like a month ago right
yeah i bought two like a month ago and
then one more recently
well i didn't i didn't buy the market
what'd you buy zach i didn't buy a full
token i just threw like i don't know
maybe a thousand bucks at it
and what price did you buy it
[ __ ] i forgot it might have been like
three thousand thirty one hundred were
you guys like talking was this something
absolutely not i don't know
you never you never share your uh
your game plan with zacky
oh
wow well this week alone it's down 26
that's brutal the problem is i i look at
it too much
like i'm in my yeah on like an hourly
basis and then you're always stressing
yeah you just gotta leave it i mean what
are you gonna do you're not gonna dude i
check in the middle of the night i wake
up to use the bathroom i'm checking it
first thing i wake up i check it so i'm
not the only one then it's not worth it
then don't even put your money in it
because it's ruining your life yeah if
it's like stressing you out that much
well no i gotta make my money back set
it and forget it
just put why don't you just put your
money in like the stock market where you
know you're going to get returns oh it's
not in the chat has a good point uh
you should have put your money in dink
doing my dude ding dong big doink is my
favorite coin i feel like a [ __ ] dink
doink
i didn't invest in it i feel like one
i am down i'll tell you exactly how much
i'm down i have it open still let's see
i'm down
1600 bucks
ouch
this thing's going
ding-dong it could be worse oh my god
that is a legendary dump
wait was it ever actually
can some can actually guys um
can somebody tell me how logan paul
isn't a straight scam artist
looking at this chart
dink doink
created by logan paul
he lied about creating it
literally rug pulled immediately
how how is guys can we talk about how
logan paul is literally a scammer
oh no i'm a strawberry oh no he's a
strawberry
can he be both um
let me tell you about banana
where's the safe moon at remember
safeman going to the moon yeah safe man
oh man they've got to be hurting right
now yeah look at how many safe moon cash
safe coins safe mars
wait what's the difference between safe
moon and
what the [ __ ] is that chart well love
and i were looking up the creator of
ethereum owns like
how much billion dollars worth of sheba
going yeah like 21 billion worth of
shiba like we couldn't believe that it's
crazy the creative ethereum yeah he owns
more than that than [ __ ] his own
token oh yeah way more that guy's so
rich it's crazy just this little dork
who made a stupid little
crypto
crazy
safe moon's going the moon baby any day
now
go back to like go back to max hit max
dan let's see
that was already pretty much on max yeah
i'm surprised it's not lower i mean it's
not on zero
it's point zero zero it's like eight
zeros wait what's the volume it says the
volume is 18 000.
go down to the volume the trading volume
is three thousand dollars
that's the market cap
[Music]
yo oh no the market cap is 270 thousand
dollars it's just the volume that was
traded on that particular day
um
anyways
safeman's going to the moon baby going
on the mountain
scam artist beats scam rsb feasting well
anyway um
i think that the bloodbath is pretty
much over um av at this point
hopefully snail's birthdays this week
and i had enough of this [ __ ]
whose birthday lena so what you gotta
you got your crypto's got to make money
to celebrate money yeah
nothing's in the budget
well in the last hour it's up seven
percent it says
that's good
we'd love to see it
one day you know
dude that's not healthy you got to get
rid of that [ __ ] you'll be like
what do you what do you mean lina's
birthdays this week you're saying lena's
birthday's on monday yeah i want to do
something nice for her yeah you can't
now [ __ ]
so what every all of your money's tied
up i'm sorry baby all my money's in
think doing
you got to get out dude it's not healthy
for you to be doing that [ __ ] yeah i
know logan might have pulled no i've
been out for a long time i literally
just why don't you just go play casino
games or something
you'd be more honest with yourself
ethan i have to say logan might have
pulled the rug but he did write the
catchiest [ __ ] crypto tune ever
you have that on your soundboard i don't
unfortunately
oh man
sucks
well
let's see we got the fresh and fit
podcast we got sexy m m's dan just
bailed
probably go take a [ __ ] this morning
there was a poop in the toilet did you
guys identify who left that there we
didn't i'm surprised we didn't talk
about this at the top of the show i
walked in the bathroom there was a
straight floater i was like guys there's
a floater
yeah like everyone went to go look at it
too i was like man it was in the men's
bathroom
i don't know if it's you guys use the
genders
we use all of them yeah that's what i
thought
there's [ __ ] all over it was small it
was a petite little poop so
so i i don't know i feel like
that rules me out man like i'm not i
think so covering my tracks it wasn't me
but if it was that would have been like
my worst nightmare
because i'm like [ __ ] shy someone often
be like oh there's a turd in the toilet
then like everyone in the office going
to look at it like they're going to
identify based on how it looks it was a
little nug man it could have been yours
it was petite
it could have been a little fika drop
someone's got it
i think it must have been love's it
could have been ian or cam
i haven't got a bathroom today
me neither i'm clogged up man yeah who
[ __ ] this morning
not me done no i feel like dan's always
in there dude
dan said he [ __ ] today but in the other
bathroom so he's the only one fasting up
to taking a dump
by the way it looked like someone
flushed and then one of them floated up
or something
could it was on a girlfriend
yeah
you have to hold that one down so i
don't i don't think someone didn't flush
it just floated back up was it in the
women's bathroom
yes oh okay
yeah i've never i i thought actually it
was gender specific but you guys are no
it's not okay you gotta go you gotta go
man all right
all right interesting well we'll have to
interrogate dan when he comes back from
leaving another
dump in the toilet i will check the
toilet after he leaves
all right well let's talk about um
fresh and fit this guy's real
interesting it's a podcast that has 500
000 subscribers on youtube
describes themselves as the world's
number one men's podcast we provide
truth to females
fitness
and finance
i think he described himself actually as
a red pill
dan we concluded you left the floater
no it wasn't me
i swear it wasn't me i did i did
poop this morning in the office but it
was in the other bathroom and the one on
the left
right the one on the left
which which gender
huh which which one the woman's
the one on the right is the one that had
the floater the men's had the floor yeah
the right had the floater right and i
said i went in the left bathroom
i thought you said the opposite no no no
no it was in the men's
oh
did you flush it can we do a forensic
analysis on that yeah
it's about to send that to the lab
all right let's talk about fresh and fit
also what's with that name what are you
doing like a subway sandwich or
something like jenny craig fresh and fit
weird name dude
so
dude their podcast is literally called
womanizer wednesday oh my god
you know that's not a good thing right
guys a womanizer
like even if you're red pill that's not
really
the way to describe yourself
so are these guys just famous for being
provocative are they from something else
i mean because i just see them in the
news all the time these days
you know i didn't have too much time to
do a deep dive on them because i was
just going into it last night but it's
in this they've only been on youtube for
one year and they have tons of
controversy surrounding them i'm not
surprised they're self-described
womanizers
well let's see
the podcast has enjoyed record growth
and success
it was set up over a little over a year
ago podcast discusses dating
commitment and features a mixed group of
men and women
here let's let's enjoy
some of their best takes
uh i want ethan to make a content court
on this actually i do too on this steamy
pile of garbage
but i guess we're talking about it now
so who knows but let's do it
you guys this what you want the wig
impromptu
no no
there's the music
i don't want to abuse the wig okay all
right all right cut them like i said
before why the hell are you gonna pay
full price for a goddamn car that's been
used what women don't understand is men
don't ask for much okay if i'm gonna
take you seriously as a girlfriend and
or a wife my only real request is that
you don't embarrass me and [ __ ] other
guys okay but they have the [ __ ] gall
to sit here and say yeah it's a care
yeah it's a cure no you dumb [ __ ] i'm
not [ __ ] insecure i'm very secure yes
you are
listen to yourself
you made a whole podcast
to try to make yourself feel more secure
about women
you literally doing womanizer wednesday
and shouting like
a cartoon character
you're so insecure bro it's actually
pathetic
this is crazy [ __ ] goal to sit here
and say yeah it's a care yeah it's a
cure no you dumb [ __ ] i'm not [ __ ]
insecure did you really put a record
scratch in there you pathetic freak
did he put that in there they got a
sound they have a little yeah he did a
record scratch yeah that's what i'm
saying dude do we have the best sound in
the game we never do we don't drop
record scratches
okay
we could
yeah maybe as homage to them i'll add it
for next time let's get some record
scratches yeah
no you dumb [ __ ]
got him here i'm very secure in my
goddamn confidence i don't want to
[ __ ] wipe up no hoe all right and i'm
tired of women out here telling dudes
small dick enemies energy
[ __ ] i'm not going to the lamborghini
dealership with 300 bands to pay 200
thousand
three for a [ __ ] pay you know what
doesn't bother me small dick energy when
people say that it doesn't bother me
actually people say i have small dick
energy sometimes guess what does guess
what it doesn't bother me
i don't even shout i need to call women
[ __ ]
i don't need to do any record scratches
or or a
symbol
crashes
you know
these dudes are textbooks someone broke
my heart they got buff dude made a
podcast hating women the first one i'll
tell you the first woman broke their
hearts their mom
i mean i i know it's brutal but it's
true
you know these women have ra these guys
usually have
mom issues which is why they hate women
so much
just it's a mommy makeout day just a
guess i mean you don't end up this
twisted for no reason
one bad breakup doesn't do this too
yeah [ __ ] i'm not going to the limit it
could be daddy issues too i don't need
to blame the mom no i think you're right
i think it is because to hate women that
much i mean
i feel like
anyone who's raised by you know a woman
would teach their son not to act that
way you know
it's not even about being taught
anything it's just about seeing what's
normal
um
yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] wipe up no hoe
all right and i'm tired of women out
here telling dudes smells like enemy
small dick energy dude
it's so awesome how that offends him so
much like uh so insecure dude
[ __ ] i'm not going to the lamborghini
dealership with 300 bands to pay 200
thousand
three for [ __ ] pay 300 000 for a
lambo with 200 000 miles on it bro it's
[ __ ] we need to start holding these
women accountable you want to do that
six feet tall oh he's making an analogy
he's gonna protect you in times of
danger take care of you be a leader six
figure [ __ ] abs all this extra [ __ ] but
you can't even be
a [ __ ] decent woman and not be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of here bro
i don't know what you're talking about
but like probably you need to
probably uh change your parameters a
little bit there if you keep ending up
with women who
i don't know dude you're not that's how
lambo is a lambo i'll take a lambo yeah
lambo's a lambo also dude i don't think
lambos do 200 000 miles just to be fair
i think those things don't clock
anywhere near that
um the man has he this man this is
classic example of gamma rage
is this gamma yeah i don't know i can't
i can't tell it might have been columbia
this might be zeta this is beta as [ __ ]
bro this is straight up yeah i mean the
top comment is perpetual single energy
it's like i mean yeah dude um
i don't know what women you're talking
to
okay but obviously
um
something is not working with the way
that you are approaching women
and in this world my friends there is
one thing you can
you can change and that's yourself
you can't change the whole world of
women
you can change yourself
you know change change
this guy's like going to like influencer
parties and then trying to take home
like instagram like influencer girls
every night and then getting angry that
none of them want to marry him or some
[ __ ]
i mean isn't the point of this podcast
to give dating advice is this i don't
know what kind of data advice this is
this is just gamma and this is just
gamma rage
yeah see also he's talking about slots
and hoes is he
insecure that they had and he's talking
about mileage he's using the car analogy
does he want a like a virgin does he
want a woman that's never been with
another man or something like
is that what his idea of a perfect woman
is or something that's what it sounds
like based on his stupid-ass car analogy
i mean i wonder how many women you slept
with dude you probably keep a tally of
it i just don't understand what's wrong
with women sleeping with other men with
men
i don't understand it
this person makes a good observation
they say
uh men like him and keem are so insecure
they want girls with no past
relationships or sexual experience
because they are terrified of being
compared to other men
you think so
it's interesting that makes that makes a
lot of sense well it definitely comes
from insecurity right because they're
not they think that
they need to be the only man in the
world because they're so insecure that
any
past experience to compare
looking out and seeing other men they're
afraid that they're going to see better
options out there so it does come from a
deep deep place of insecurity there's
really no other explanation for it
he also sounds like charlie day you know
what i mean it's like always sunny rant
like i said before why the hell right
here he hits that joke
[ __ ] i'm not going to the lamborghini
dealership with 300 bands to pay 200
thousand three for
on the rant a little bit when you start
stumbling over every other word let's
see
[Laughter]
so this this girl brittany renner
confronted them on saying
they are warning men about women like
her this is fantastic this went viral
lately
of her absolutely
destroying
these fools
actually exposing too straight just how
insecure and beta they are
fresh great idea was don't tell mario
until today so wait this is an eight
minute clip am i is this whole thing
good to watch because what i saw was
only like 30 seconds well i could find a
shorter one but i don't want to watch it
all of it good i thought it was good it
just like she confronts them and they
completely [ __ ] breaks like they're
doing everything together
and we're like we're thinking you're
probably gonna be like okay [ __ ] we're
gonna have this great debate but you
said you said initially like yeah i
don't think there's much to really
like debate why
well i mean
we here's the thing we've always said
like
men and women were very different we
have opposing goals like girls are
trying to you know get resources time
attention out of guys guys are trying to
get sex and
girls a lot of the time are trying dude
you need new friends she's already like
men only want sex
we don't want resources family comfort
love
we just want sex
and women on the other hand
they don't like sex
in fact they avoid it
they only want resources
clothing cars shoes
and sex is a tool they use
to get those things
this is the world of the of the gamma
mail trying to get what they need to get
attitudes without necessarily giving it
up and some girls are good at it some
girls aren't and then there's other
girls that are kind of models for that
that are good at finessing dudes and not
to say that you're a finesser i ain't
saying that but
girls are able to you know run laps
around a lot of guys and that's why our
podcast exists to help dudes out to
understand like how women operate and
how they move this guy is no game
dude if anyone should be given that
seminar it's not you
well he's given a seminar on something
that's not it doesn't exist so i guess
you can be the the guru of any
discipline you create out of thin air
your point of view wait wait where do
you think she fits in that because you
know
i i think
her point of view would be diametrically
opposed to you guys by saying well
well
i'm not the exact typical person who
you may think dudes or running into her
you're trying to tell people to stay
away from
i mean well sir she could tell she was
saying that we're wrong i guess about
that can you tell us a little bit about
yourself no i think you know more about
me than i do myself so you're saying no
no
obviously you do though because you said
that you warned guys about girls like me
so tell me about girls like me
human in general like i mean well no no
don't women in general because you
literally specifically said before we
got on here
yeah you did say that that's true you
warned guys about girls like me so now
that we're face to face
what kind of girl am i
you're not special you're like other
girls
i'm not special
oh my god she's actually so much smarter
than him
and what she's saying is really smart
and true i mean
you made this huge generalization about
women you said girls like her she says
okay tell me about myself
she's exactly right he has nothing to
say
he can't even make eye contact with her
he's looking around yeah because he's
singing face to face and probably he's
intimidated by a strong beautiful woman
that he knows he has no chance with and
that's where the rage comes from
uh that's straight up gamma ray i keep
saying that people can think i'm serious
yeah the dude is so insecure and my
homie here doesn't even say [ __ ] ever
like what's the beta energy here in the
corner
take that medallion off bro you got to
say something before you get a big fresh
medallion literally this dude hasn't
said [ __ ]
his only job is to look fresh this is
the other guy is that he's the fit one
right
uh it's so satisfying to watch these
guys get absolutely schooled what makes
you special then
i never said i was but you're trying to
say what makes no she's right
you're saying you're not special
that makes you feel well i am special
i know about you know
you're the you're the one that can
identify who's special and who's not
right very special
you're very special dude
it can be different from like a lot of
women operate the way you do
and how do i operate yeah what does that
mean in general what i just said before
women it's a dance between the two
genders men are trying to get sex women
are trying to get resources time
attention whatever it is that they're
looking for
and a lot of girls play the game better
than guys we talk about this openly on
our podcast and we're teaching guys how
to not necessarily do his homemade
but they're not able to get it but girls
are easily able to obtain money time
resource attention whatever it is girls
are running laps wrong dudes which is
why podcasts like ours exist
do you believe that brittany has been
effective in
extracting as you say time resources and
other things out of dues
yeah to a degree sure yeah i mean like
a lot of girls want to do i mean here's
the thing you've been so adamant about
me being incorrect and i i don't know
and you don't know me and all this other
stuff tell me then maybe maybe who knows
well i think first of all
let's
bring it back a couple notches
okay
so
[Music]
there's really a lot to unpack here
because my first question to you is what
do you gain from telling girls that
they're not special how does that make
you feel
i mean i know everything i know
everything is a joke but i'm asking you
a real question so how does that make
you feel because if i say you're a
bitch-ass [ __ ] that does something for
me
right if i insult you or if i tell
you're not special you're forgettable
what does that do for me no but that
doesn't that's what i'm saying no but
i'm but i'm saying
what if i call you if i just say that
again you're forgettable that's why i
didn't want to do you guys podcast
forgettable hate the setup uh the name
is underwhelming i didn't really see the
value in it
right that's how i feel oh my god dude
he's so owned right now
he's feels like a little boy again
he's back to when he was a little boy
growing up which is where all this
trauma began
look how little he looks he looks like a
child
and he is a child
it's sad that this guy can't ever grow
up he's stuck
as a side note academics keeps moving
her microphone to adjust it when i could
hear her perfectly but i can't hear
academics at all
his mic is super low just something
funny pay attention to
wait who's suggesting what mike the guy
in the middle he keeps adjusting
the host yeah he keeps adjusting the
girl's mic but i could hear her
perfectly but his mic is like sounds
like it's not on he could barely hear
him hmm
interesting observation there right but
so that's fine but
for me
that's okay if it wasn't a fit for me
but i also don't need to
you know in a way kind of try to devalue
what you guys have going on because at
the end of the day i might not agree
with anything you guys talk about
because honestly i feel like when you've
seen two or three videos you've seen
them all
but the reality is is that i went to
your guys's page and i went to the
different links and the different
services and the courses that you guys
offer and i do see that there's a place
for that so even though it may not have
been in alignment with what i am about
i can still give credit where it's due
without trying to devalue you guys
because you guys are doing something
special right
because you guys are i mean so good cam
that's literally him bro
alpha sigma beta gamma omega he sounds
just like charlie dave so it's pretty
amazing are there a lot of other people
doing what you do you could consider
your guys's podcast special right i
think what she's mentioned is like the
self self help portion for dudes where
you guys offer services so you know help
guys you know either attract or or you
know try to talk talk and bang these
guys for a class you engage with them at
a higher rate that you could you know
potentially one of them doesn't even
talk for christ's sake
that dude is so quiet
date them right yeah yeah well i i guess
i guess the point that i think she's
disagreeing with right when
i'm simply asking her to tell us about
herself because we were so incorrect oh
my god bro you got owned so hard the
host has to interject to like
try to get a response out of him
he's so embarrassed right now it's
amazing so tell us about yourself that's
all i'm saying and then well
attacking us no no one's attacking you
because like i said i never listen
there's a lot of people that will not
sit down and have a conversation with
you just because of the comments that
you guys made well you made and well you
chimed in so you guys are tweeted and
tweeted out kind of right so i'm here to
have a conversation with you guys
because for me i feel like what a lot of
mailed mail so he's like yo you're
insulting me it's like don't you
do that all day
you insult women
all day and so when you're face to face
someone that's bringing that's actually
trying to talk to you and confront you
you turn into a little [ __ ]
a little baby
dominated podcasts are missing is the
bridge of understanding so i came here
not to argue you guys or to call you out
of your name or to disrespect what
anybody's doing because i i felt like
the interview i had with him there were
things that he said i didn't agree with
but i wanted to sit down and hear his
point of view so that's what i'm trying
to do here so for you to say you're not
special well i'm special to someone just
like you're special to someone just like
he's special to someone so are you
trying to
all groups of women then we would have
to take it back to where this even began
like why you even have this view of
women and every like i said you have a
bunch of dumbass [ __ ] on your guys
podcast and i get it they don't
challenge you and i know you're a really
smart guy but it's like
i feel like you need to kind of just be
honest and show people who you really
are
like i know that for people to be
dragging you guys and say take this
little clip and say that's who you are
that's not true so that's why i sat down
and had this conversation is he really
gonna have nothing to say here to
degrade you
so when you make comment let me see what
i'm saying when you make comments like
oh yeah no women are special so no woman
is special but yet you guys have a whole
podcast dedicating how to get women just
for sex that's all you guys are so
you're saying men are just limited to
just sex that's all they care about is
sex
yes or no that's what i don't care about
there's no i'm just saying they're
laughing and answering the question
it's just my dick [ __ ] sex i want a hole
wow you are triggered man wow wow oh my
god dude
absolutely embodied let's see what you
have to say
she wanted a whole lot right there
honestly it's just i speak with
conviction
yeah i mean for you to say girls like me
i'm they're cutting out his response or
something just like okay well i'm
assuming if i go off of what it's pretty
amazing how his his sidekick his
henchmen there didn't say a single word
to be honest you're not really making a
point
i said at the top
men and women it's a delicate dance
between the two genders to get what they
want correct i said men want sex women
want resources attention
money time whatever it is from a man
changes per girl some girls want money
some girls want attention some girls
want time while some girls want a hot
guy whatever it is no girl wants sex in
this guy's world
that's crazy that's sad
they're only the only people they have
sex with is against their will
apparently
nobody enjoys sex
there's a multivariate requirement for
women of what they want okay
wow
i love how academics was mansplaining
the whole time what she meant was he was
translating for her like she doesn't
speak english
but she was trying to say well he was
just trying to elicit a response from
the guy because he's just sitting there
like a [ __ ]
here is their uh this is one of their
websites i found on their social media
the only way left for the normal guy is
to become a high value ma'am
fresh and fit giving away they're
jealously guarded secrets for scoring
nines and tens
wow
and more this is pathetic wait and more
and more eleven elevens oh [ __ ]
literally off the [ __ ]
scale are you seriously ready to pull
nines and tens and more
[Laughter]
let's watch this video i bet it's good
uh oh i'm muted hold on these guys don't
know anything about dating that's the
thing like i mean
obviously for you like money isn't
really a thing in november december 2016
would make this week of the thirty
thousand dollars in one week ecstatic
there's no way around it in 2021.
that's when i made the mill in a week of
8 million weeks yeah yeah
they're just talking about money
and then asking people to go on patreon
i still haven't seen this dude say a
word
that's not him we got some big things
coming guys
this website the only way people like
these guys make money is fleecing more
pathetic dudes or you know all these
gurus self-help guys who talk about how
to make money they all make money just
from fleecing
this website design is something else
i mean it's typical
conversion page [ __ ] yeah
whoa
get in now i still haven't seen that
other guy talk
i could say every time the other guy
talks it's a self-report
every every clip i've seen where he does
open his mouth he kind of self-reports
somehow he does talk so here i've got
another one
yo this course costs 700 [ __ ]
high value academy yeah the only high
value is their
how to aesthetically fit
starting a business making money
yeah i love it's just that easy start a
business yeah
here's the first lesson use the gta 5
font
gta 5.
finance investing high level networking
dating professionalism dudes giving
courses on professionalism yeah
definitely
that's awesome i kind of want to take
the course
don't give these guys let's see if
people are interested to do uh
well it's fine we can sign up and then
do a chargeback not kidding
just kidding
so here's another clip there's so many
of them this guy they say they don't
date black women straight up just no no
black women what about the black dating
app called black
it's funny i never use that one bro but
hey man
i mean hey bro if you want to date a
bunch of shaniquas go for it man
laquisha yeah like
me and fresh aren't really down with the
brown like that we ain't night riders so
i'm good uh you know sometimes if
they're you know red bones like in
general me and fresh uh don't dabble in
the dark if you know what i'm saying yep
um okay so last one guys uh
good thing the spoken code there
now we're not going to mention names for
certain reasons right for a bunch of
legal implications but if you guys are
you know in our
in our community we talk about this
extent what about the black dating app
called black
they don't take black women yeah they
hate they hate their moms i mean how
else can you describe that
like
you're all the women in your family are
black your your sisters your moms
everyone that you apparently i don't
know apparently don't love but yeah i
mean they obviously hate their moms
right they're like i don't date black
women
weirdos
uh i don't even know here's the whole
thrift she is so
i don't care simple
damn um
guys guys guys sidebar sidebar
conversations please all right what i've
told you this is like you know this is
like the fifth time i've told you that
right
like stop for real like stop hey man
it's [ __ ] up
yeah it's the whole show yeah she's been
doing the whole show i'm not mean as
[ __ ] i just have rules simple all right
good it's buckas damn um
by the way as someone that operates a
podcast
um when you have
two four six seven eight nine he has
nine people in the room with nine mics
there's gonna be sidebars bro that's a
lot that's like a [ __ ] whole crowd of
people okay
um what the [ __ ] is this setup
what i look for in a man
that's like approaching me hold on
excuse me dude you better oh no
what the [ __ ] is that you can't do the
record scratch what the [ __ ] is that he
literally and he did his own record
scratch you see him hit it [ __ ]
insult dude let's let's content court
the [ __ ] out of these guys i swear there
has to be more than enough
yeah this is just [ __ ] on twitter i mean
there's apparently a year's worth of
content from them you me i'm not mean at
all okay i don't care have you been here
the whole time i know all right then so
you don't know what was happening right
okay then so how are you gonna come on
somebody's show not know go down and say
oh you're mean it don't matter i can say
what i want okay we can get the [ __ ] off
the show
especially when the other dude was like
yo
uh oh he's getting criticized by another
man i wonder if it that homie's higher
on the sexual hierarchy chart and then
maybe that's why he's shutting down very
calm but it's like like bro you got to
show a little bit of respect
bro he's just clearly a gemini it is
what it is what the [ __ ] do you think
his mercury's in rising
yeah i think it it it's risen it's
straight up
fully up dude
mercury is these are the types of dudes
by the way who would like talk so much
[ __ ] about astrology now i think
astrology is dumb don't get me wrong but
they're they have their own
pseudoscience while being like
astrology's so stupid
anyway i'm a gamo
my game isn't rising
you grown as hell
what yeah well okay okay okay okay so
earlier on the show this guy has lost
control of his own show he's shutting
down
look at him he's like raging he's
shutting down and once again can't make
a trigger in his parlance he's triggered
he's so triggered right now and yeah
he's avoiding eye contact amy you're
right
he's only capable of looking at the man
in the room because it was like five
times like chill yeah so that's way okay
but i said he mean what he why he want
to earn right that's a good point
because you don't know what was going on
that she's right she's like i just said
you're mean
you lost your [ __ ] mind
it's good bro
all right we all right this is the guy
trying
okay just just like from here on out
like please one at a time because
you started over i was almost saying
nothing i promised the fifth time you
said that last time yes yes
did you have nine people in a small tiny
room
listen dude let them down his food
also apparently they're drinking too
based on the red cups there i mean
did he just bail right where you paused
it looked like the guy oh dude
i'm just talking to general don't get me
beat up but
no no no no we don't know the door i
think he's out
there
dude he left he got so triggered he left
his own podcast
jesus that's awesome
what a baby and all she said is that
he's mean
he he has so much rage towards women
this shit's scary dudes like him
yeah big dudes who work out and they
can't control their emotions and [ __ ]
like that those are the ones you really
need to look out for for sure
yeah i mean he talks about how no
women's worthy of him and
i would say
i
i
i agree uh but opposite i don't think
anyone i don't think this guy's ready
for a relationship i think he needs
therapy lots of it what's his name my
myron
fought for tomorrow
dj says
700 self-help course to act like this
storm out of his own podcast
dan when isn't all set down
all the other girls
his friend trying to act like it's all
good
all right um oh my god
and then we
yeah
say whatever you ladies want bullied off
your own show i want to hear what y'all
have to say
yeah um cool so we're gonna uh end this
show here shortly
and then his his dude can't even carry
the show
obviously on the show he's panicking
and um chris
chris please chris help help me chris
um
let's close up yeah yeah good decision
to roll out asian don't come on
someone's show not knowing oh what's
going on and speaking down the on the
host respect the show yeah facts yeah uh
first time donating just say myron is a
real one don't change so now he's
reading mean comments from his insult
fans in front of the other ladies who
are
apparently sitting there having a
conversation and he's acting like
they're not even there for nobody yeah
[ __ ] out of here bro we don't change
uh i don't even know who she is so
i don't care that's kevin girl like
you don't know who queen vaughan is no i
know who king vaughan is but i mean you
should know who his girl is
so uh
anything else
we caught up all right cool uh with that
said uh guys thank you for coming in i
think it's just incredible that these
guys actually have
a fan thumb
um
that's incredible i mean
half a million people subscribed to this
train wreck
oh man
traits of feminine women what's her gram
what's your strengths
that's crazy i ain't gonna like just
keep it real yeah they're drinking white
claws and he's like i have a room full
of nine people drinking
and i'm getting angry that two of them
are are having a side a small size i
really date black girls
it's not because like no no like like
most black girls are like annoying how
to put this ratchet and they don't know
how to like be reserved
you're like the opposite you are not the
stereotype that you are not the stars
you're not the same that's awesome yeah
so we'll give you that complimentary
instagram
yo literally hate all black people but
you're one of the good ones
so take that as a huge compliment
oh she goes oh yeah
yo can i get your instagram by the way
oh boy
it's funny i never used that one bro but
hey man
i mean hey bro if you want a date a
bunch of shaniquas go for it man
yeah then they backtrack later on it's
in the dock where they're like oh we
were just talking about our preferences
not about it's like no you weren't
talking about your dating preference
uh let's see
is this one oh my god there's so much is
this a new one uh maybe or did i was
referring to the previous mainstream
media it just wants to make us look a
certain way because they're because
obviously we'll talk guys the red pill
is in the mainstream that we we've we uh
us
uh are pretty much i won't even sound
cocky we're at the forefront right now
of bringing the rpm to the mainstream
and bringing the what
rpm red pill
mail
oh rpms oh i don't know i don't know
about my pay grade he just mentioned red
pill was the only reason i recognized
the acronym there
ah this is sad
you gotta remember guys most people
do not want to resist the slave mind
they they they want to be in the slave
mind so we talk about you know
cryptocurrency being in the of course
they're in the crypto what a shock
redfield
this is the this is the male version of
damaged goods you know what i mean
pendant uh being an entrepreneur uh not
letting women control your life looking
at the world from a red lens versus
looking at the world from a blue lens
a lot of people are not used to looking
at the world this way you know what i'm
saying everyone thinks women are right
you're wrong your women are champions
let's pedestalize them whatever so we go
in there and say nah you got to make
girls uncomfortable or whatever
everyone's like what the what the what
whoa that's childish they just use a
jontron drop on their show that was
jontron going what
i don't know
yeah yeah that was it i recognized it
you know what i'm saying like there
so many people guys are not aware you
know what i'm saying you guys got to
remember that the rp is still a
relatively new thing and most guys don't
know it yeah
it's a new thing to be a chauvinist this
is this is a brand new concept in uh the
history of civilization of the invented
being yeah
looking down on women and thinking of
them as lesser this is a this is a brand
new it's revolutionary basically 21st
century thinking baby we're taking over
the world also based on the past two
videos we've seen women make you
uncomfortable not the other way around
they're they're well stated they seem
very comfortable actually you're the one
that left your own podcast
the only pill you'll be taking is uh
beta brain is uh what do you call the
melatonin because you'd be sleeping
man
yeah it just wants to make us look a
certain way because they're because
obviously yo real talk guys the red pill
is in the mainstream that we he's like
yo listen bro this new movement i'm
saying i don't want women to vote
i don't want them to be able to get
abortions that should be our decision
i don't want them to be able to leave
the house they got to walk behind us
this is a new kind of [ __ ] we're dealing
with yeah i'm coming out with a
revolutionary idea it's going to change
the world nobody's ever done this before
i think the government should be run
by old
white males those are the only people
that i know and he's like hey and i
don't even like
i can't even say it because people take
it out of context but you know i was
going to say his words not mine
yeah dude it's revolutionary
and as you guys know women don't like
sex so we got to keep them at home
you just knock them up with babies you
give them like food and shelter which is
all they want
oh i'm telling you and we're going to
call this new world uh
uh
what was the name of that country and
handmade entail
oh
[Music]
god damn it gideon something
gilead
yeah we're going to call it gilead guys
wait they went on tent pool
yeah you're gonna like this you're gonna
like this what a crossover you guys no
shot they went on temple let me just say
one thing too for a lot of people what
what is wrong with him well you gotta
watch him he's based hold on i'm on it
asking about
vaguely about something that you guys
are accused of doing that i don't know
anything about and they're they're
they're super chatting as if i would
know what it is but i can i can't i
can't ask you just the simple one adam
griffin says can you ask why these
clowns tried to take down abba and
preach with fake dmca strikes what
you want to go into it yeah it's it's uh
so so basically uh we have a lot of
people that talk about us on internet
and some of it is slander some of his
defamation and using our content in
their videos and we're like okay cool
we've waited out for a while for you to
stop you're still doing it so oh you
know what cool now we're going to take
legal action against you because
obviously we're attacking our character
in our integrity what he's doing
actually is he's admitting that he
followed them in bad faith he's opened
himself to a lawsuit basically an
instant l well guess what
tim agrees
really at that point eight is all for a
game yeah i mean yeah wow simply put if
someone breaks into your store right and
use it takes a broom off you have a
hardware store takes a broom off the
shelf and starts beating you with your
own broom and won't leave and doesn't
idiot
wow wait wait you know what we need for
that cannot [ __ ] you know what we
need for that
oh
we got our own records
guys we just figured out and get in
their new country of gilead no free
speech you're not allowed to to you're
not allowed to use anybody's speech
against them once it's been spoken you
can't criticize them you can't show
clips of their footage
no free speech guys these guys are true
secure warriors
hey you can't use my words against me
how dare you it's not like i live in
[ __ ] america freedom of speech
douchebags
holy god okay tim let's see what you got
this is a layup so damn yeah but still
for four months what are you gonna do
well you can't file a dmca over it
apparently not yeah so what they just
get it reversed or what yeah it's it's
it's a long story but
basically
simply put the challenges
when it comes to public failures and
defamation cases is really hard to win
it is yeah but you know look i i
actually tell people we we've got people
who rip off our members only content
which is actually
probably not fair use
so if like if i downloaded your video
well if they just re-uploaded
depending on yeah
video by video but yeah very difficult
to win that but i've got people who go
to go to timcast.com take those behind a
paywall publish them on you know online
and then comment on them that's fair use
tim
100 fair use now that's the line i don't
go after them still though like they
they take clips out of context they make
stuff up i should ignore it it's
probably the best thing to do
he's right and it's the legal thing to
do and when you want to when you want to
be at least tim is consistent at this
point he's this uh red-blooded american
at least in this case you know he is uh
taking the correct he's never dmc at us
so no it's a low bar but i just uh i
appreciated his the bluntness of his
reply when he made that incredibly
terrible analogy of uh you can't go in
my shop and use my own broom to beat me
up
what would you do about it he's like
well not file a dnca the creators that
they uh went after responded abba and
preach they're pretty good responses i
put it here in the dock
to him talking about the broom analogy
wait what's their name i think i know
that abba and preach is it two blocked
out yeah does it do reactions they're
pretty funny i think yeah they're really
cool again i don't know anything about
them so don't like you know try to
cancel me because i said i like them you
[ __ ] up but they're pretty funny
they're actually funny yeah well i i
watch the clip that a b is talking about
it it's really [ __ ] okay so let's so
so that's nice
okay
but this is this is where people are so
that one of the questions about
copyright infringement and fair uses i
don't know are you infringing on
someone's marketing no it's that sorry
that's what i was going to say because
fair use depends on different countries
it's different where depending where you
are no phrase is an american doctrine
you dumb ass you don't know anything
fair use depends on different countries
where are you located dude
what country are you sitting in right
now
that's actually a good question are they
american they could be canadian or
something i don't know
fresh fresh and pit podcast american
they're american
awesome they're in america tim poole is
in america they're podcasters shot in
florida there you go yeah
but i'm pretty sure regardless well okay
let's watch but a big thing on fair use
where you know it hurts your ability to
get protected by fair uses are you
hurting that other person's ability to
profit from their own product but this
is this is
how is him making a reaction video
preventing you from profiting dude
specific it basically means also fair
like very like let's say a critic of a
film
he writes a scathing review of a movie
and so as a result people don't go watch
that movie less people go watch that
movie that's still protected speech my
dude
okay
like if uh
if you're a photojournalist and you sell
photos for a living
and then you post one you post a sample
on twitter and you say to license this
photo buy it here and then people start
posting it everywhere now you've got
copyright infringement because
even though it's online even though it's
newsworthy and even though people are
commenting on it they're infringing on
your market because you directly sell
this content which means you said
license it from me if you guys do a
publicly available show and people post
and comment on it you got no case you
can't you can't dmca it so for us what
i'm saying is on our website we have a
paywall if you want to watch the video
you're actually wrong
if someone then takes that post it
online and says i'm commenting on it
nope no dice that's why you can't post
he's just talking at his ass he's
totally wrong about that just movies on
youtube but just say like you you can't
post a movie while watching it and go
wow that well that's not fair use no
matter what you're watching tim it's
crazy because you're literally taking
away the the the market share from from
you know from the business these guys
they're all wrong man
and it's funny how they all like spin it
just to protect their own like uh
their own investments and stuff he's
like well my paywall says i can't do
this well this one's uh this guy's
saying mean things about me so he can't
do that
uh abba and preach
respond to these absolute [ __ ] who
dmca their video
and literally admitted that it was bad
faith
these guys should sue them with your own
broom and won't leave and does it for
four months
what are you gonna do
what the [ __ ] is he talking about yeah
let me let me what happened is that you
have a store that you sell brooms and we
told you that that bro what's crazy
about these two guys is both of them
talk
one of them isn't like a weird beta that
like masturbates with his tears in the
corner
well the other one does all the talking
is garbage that's what we did
we left the google review
that's what we did we left the google
review saying
your broom asked me for a fight now that
broom don't want to fight and that broom
doesn't pick up this that's what we did
wait what is he saying that did he he
said because he gave an analogy of
imagine you have a broom store a fresh
and fit and someone comes in and takes a
broom and then starts to hit you with it
and he's like we didn't do that he's
like we bought a broom and gave it a
google review
yeah well that's true actually because
like i said if they make a negative
review that results in people watching
them less that's protected speech
that's what we did
that's the only thing that we did we
didn't break into nothing we didn't
steal nothing we told you your broom is
not doing what it's supposed to do you
guys know what it's claiming to do and
that broom challenged me into a fight
when i showed up and i wanted to show up
that broom turned into a dustpan
that's what happened okay so we left the
google review
and that's not illegal no it's not darn
bro well you can't file a dmca over it
apparently not yeah apparently
it's it's it's a long story but
it's not a long story it's not a lot of
course youtube was like yo what the [ __ ]
is this yo take this [ __ ] down and your
little [ __ ] ass ran to you to be like
uh we're retracting it please don't
delete our channel please don't do it he
retracted and you retracted all your
strikes don't be acting about it's a
long story no stupid you did the wrong
thing right susan wojowski just came in
there with a long slung and slapped you
that's what happened and it's okay but
don't make it sound like it's a long
story and also
shout out to teachers these guys are
funny they're the way they play off each
other it's great
who said
uh that's not how it works he just
yeah you didn't hear what he said no
it's not me and won't leave and does it
for four months
what are you going to do
well you can't file a dmca over it
apparently not
[Music]
yeah tim's like uh well you can't do
what you guys did
[Laughter]
tim doesn't know
he doesn't know what happened tim
doesn't know what happened but he just
went off what they told them
you want a bias from someone that didn't
know what happened
then there you go seems like that's not
that's not what happened that's not your
response if somebody breaks into you
call the police you can't just go and
shoot up their place yeah that's awesome
man they're getting dunked on by
everyone
as they should
uh welcome to a free society where when
you say dumb [ __ ] people get to respond
okay
yeah dan was saying that they're going
to try to dmcs but we'll see about that
if you or block or something i don't
know at the minute 37 mark of their
video it's pretty good they're talking
about his partner they're pretty much
saying the same thing that the guy never
talks
oh for real in the same video yeah at
the minute 37
minute
37
let's see
god damn it
can you ask why these clowns tried to
take down abba and preach with fake dmca
strikes what
you want to go into it
yeah it's it's a hey no wonder you don't
want to talk about it yeah it's funny
because it's the same i i i that he did
when you went on there live and you
asked the question straight up so i just
want to ask you about that why do you
think i might be blue built um well from
what i know blue pill i'm trying to
remember i would say uh
like
i'm trying to i'm trying to think like
which video was
oh yeah so what's up yeah i heard you
were talking to the podcast
what did i say and then
well actually what you said and fresh
through him under the bus
fresh is so unaware and lacking in any
awareness think about this so so
basically uh we have a lot of people
that talk about us on internet and some
of it is slander some of his defamation
and using our content in their videos
and we're like okay cool we've waited
out for a while for you to stop you're
still doing it so oh you know what cool
now we're going to take legal action
against you because obviously we're
attacking our
integrity so at that point hey it's all
for a game yeah i mean yeah okay so i
want you guys to be what he said he said
yeah we did copyright strikes against
you saying you misused our content why
because you attacked our character
criticism
yeah i mean these guys are smart the
other guys are dumb it's basically just
those guys are such easy layups man it's
sad that people actually listen to them
i mean my god there's so much more
interesting and smart people in the
world than those two bozos
it really is
this guy's name oh is this his man
is he posting cringe on his main yeah
look at the caption
oh on that one yeah
number one men's podcast in the world
actually you know what we're the number
one men's podcast in the world
i'm saying it men and women are welcome
to join well apparently anybody can just
make that declaration i'm saying it
right now we're the number one men's and
the number one swimmers joe rogan would
probably constitute the number one
men's yeah
in the world
the caption is my face when a bimbo says
the wage gap exists because of sexism
and the patriarchy that's your face
that's your name that's your face when
she says that
that's not how the meat works at all
this guy deserves all the the gooning
he's getting
hope you found the talk to your man
you've been looking for
i love it i hope this guy comes after us
in response because i'd love to get into
it with him easy layup easy w
come debate me dude i'll be your blue
pill i'll be a blue pale debate yo you
want to be red bill let's go i'll be
straight gamma male energy call in
let's go man
wage gap uh wage gap me daddy
[Music]
a full-on war are we blowing the warhorn
more of a skirmish at this point yeah
really this is more of a scouting
mission we haven't even reached the uh
skirmish yet
yeah we're we're scouting to see if
there's a battle ahead right i'm up for
it though yeah
i wish that we could battle like i want
to take over their podcast and then like
take all their audience like soflo did
to me back in the day you go to war and
whoever wins gets all their subscribers
just conquer them yeah i want to conquer
that they're the fresh and fit podcasts
can we just grab fit and fresh or
something
we should make a new podcast called the
fit and fresh
and just take over their seo yeah
yeah call me dude i want to debate you
the baby beta
look at me i have the ultimate alpha a
bust of the ultimate alpha on my desk
sir dr jordan peterson
and by the way right now huh
you guys want to order food by the way
i'm living on m m's
so if you want i'm all sexed up on brown
and green eminem i know we haven't even
talked about that let's talk about the
success
all right you guys
now let me just say
for those of you out in public this part
might be too graphic
lots of uh
let's say
skin
it might get you going it might get you
uh
[Music]
thirsty
i'll let me just put this the fit and
fresh guys probably
couldn't handle themselves
around these m ms
because they are hot
they are sexy oh
wow
oh
talent telling you
so eminem made up this press release it
starts here and this story is amazing so
you all are going to want to watch this
um
candy is about to get more inclusive
with the makers of eminem announcing its
faint characters are getting modern
makeovers that will make them more
nuanced personalities
i mean the whole thing's so stupid from
top to bottom been
praying for so long yeah that they will
add more nuance to my m ms you know it's
just it makes such a difference when i
know that uh
my yellow m m is uh
my yellow eminem has is
is uh supporting trans right yeah well
my blue eminem
he's a uh blue m m's overweight
over uh obese eminem yeah oh
fat uh it's fat acceptance mukbang lives
matter yeah
the the orange enemy's a cop
the orange one is actually a [ __ ]
he's actually neurodivergent
no he's a cop and blue lives matter
i'm telling you
the red m m
we don't talk about the red eminem i
think the reason is [ __ ] up the red's
the cop he's [ __ ] up dude
the remnants help
the green is the skank
she hasn't only fans
and the brown
she's your girl boss
right
straight girl boss in it straight girl
boss love them all
so
nuanced personalities
as part of the new mission
increase the sense of belonging for 10
million people around the world
thank god that is my favorite part wait
why only 10 million why why only 10
million and why are we putting a
timeline on this
by 2025 10 million people on planet
earth will increase their sense of
belonging
that is the mars company promise yeah i
mean look we all have lofty goals you
know like the united states recently
pledged to like cut their carbon
emissions by half by you know 20 30.
well mars is is planning to
make 10 people 10 million people
increase their sense of belonging via
news news how do you quantify
a sense of belong
oh well i don't know i mean the yellow m
m
this yellow m m means more to me than
you can ever imagine
fat acceptance
no i don't think healthy at everything
the blue one is the overweight one this
below m m means more to me than you
could ever know
fat acceptance
shout out
i think we all went anyway blah blah
blah we all win when we see women in
leading roles
so
okay whatever who gives a [ __ ] um
the point is
that here's the rebrand
so let's take a look
so orange hasn't changed he's like
what's wrong with orange who wants to be
orange gamma energy all day i told you
he's neurodivergent oh i'm orange eminem
take it easy on him
yeah he's neurodivergent eminem
red is the cop he's a narc look at him
yeah [ __ ] her right eminem arrogant
[ __ ] yeah who wants to be red m m okay
yellow
still i guess fat i don't know
i guess blue is kind of fat too
but here's where the problems begin
let's look at green m m
actually looks at the identical
oh so she showed leg maybe
well they all did they don't have skin
tones anymore now they're just kind of
cartoons and she had like i i don't know
that you could even call it sexy
but it has like
heels right
not really sexy it's just a boot
with heels
and so she they gave her a tennis shoe
that was the big change there and then
the brown eminem
honestly not really doesn't appear to
have changed at all
again the skin tone has been toned down
i guess here she's more open and here
she's more like oh
i don't have time for you
tucker
yeah but it seems like the green one
they just gave
tennis shoes instead of boots
the right wing conserva sphere has
completely had a meltdown culture war
love what do you think about this uh
uh come on mom can you believe this is a
on the news and [ __ ] yeah it's crazy
because they're we i was talking to them
with it about this before and it's clear
that they they probably wanted people to
be upset because you think so they are
[ __ ]
like
you couldn't pay for such like
advertising well here i am
this is a perfectly planned
advertisement
don't fall for it
and moreover
as a lot of people have pointed out the
parent company of m m's mars along with
nestle and
one other company are currently
battling a child slavery lawsuit oh for
real yeah oh my god oh so that's what i
was just going to bring up is actually
the brown eminem is the child slave
oh actually i think that one's the green
here let me show you where
the green is actually the child slave
okay uh and and i have good reason for
saying so um
the green one is actually the slave
master so his life also matters there
you go
so they're also changing the shapes of
them all this is why i was saying the
blue one's overweight he's like they're
getting new shapes yeah and then look
how tiny the green one is that's your
chances
definitely
yeah so but yeah the blue one he's a
white boy he's thick mm-hmm chilled
he's content showdown
[Laughter]
so well okay so um
tucker carlson
is outraged outraged
by this
the eminem's are not sexy anymore you
guys
now
if you happen to be a watcher of this
tucker caution show
after watching this you really have to
ask yourself
why
why
okay
that's it
the other big change is that the brown
eminem has quote transitioned from high
stilettos to lower block heels okay also
hold the phone
hold the phone
i didn't notice the difference in the
browser they look the same okay but here
let's let's we don't have an eye for
fashion yeah that's to be fair
maybe oh i see yeah it used to be a
stiletto dan more sexy
and now
is it the brown eminem has quote
transitioned from high stilettos to
lower block heels
also sexy that's progress yeah m ms will
not be satisfied until every last
cartoon character is deeply unappealing
and totally androgynous yo these m m's
are busted
i am trying to
nut
every time i see that green m m drawing
what a clown what a dumb
[ __ ] weirdo he's so desperate to
cause division
and culture war anyone that watched this
really needed to wake the [ __ ] up this
dude is literally preaching about
eminem's not being sexy enough
and therefore society is downward
downward spiraling until the moment you
wouldn't want to have a drink with any
one of them that's the goal what's an
eminem [ __ ] i'm not having a drink
with any of them or any cartoon
character for that matter he's been
looking more proud broadly about cartoon
characters in general and how they can't
be sexy holy [ __ ]
dude hentai fan uh tucker here
yeah you know actually he could be a
good guest on the fresh and fit podcast
they could have a really lively debate
about the brown eminem totally turned
off
we've achieved equity they've won
i'm sorry but this man literally
delivered a serious monologue
i don't have a boner they've won
the other
big women should be out in the world to
turn me on okay
hi stiletto heels
boots first of all makes my dick soft
women should wear stilettos just like
that eminem
the m m no longer wears stilettos oh
here uh
light up whoa whoa you can't show that
on the [ __ ] show
[Music]
oh also it's king
because it's green it's time to light up
the runway from something from my
private collection oh no
tucker we made you the green eminem
flesh ball
[Music]
just to commemorate what real women look
like
sexy sexy time
yeah
never only used once tucker so it's
basically
just wash it out it's titties you can
put it in the
dishwasher
you may not want to put anything else in
there with it
yeah if you've used it you know what i
mean you got a solo solo on that
[Laughter]
women are meant to make my dick hard
okay and these m m's are destroying
everything
now i like my mistress to use the tip of
a stiletto to step on my dick jesus
this flat shoot
[ __ ] is not going to achieve the same
ends
okay
this is the state this is the most
popular news show in america
what do you think was the harder loss uh
the green m m or lola bunny from space
jam
oh that's so true i mean lolo was
actually like come on
that's so true
lola was a huge loss
we'll never recover to the to the furry
community but i don't know did tucker do
a whole segment about lola no longer
being hot
he may have
he may know that
yeah of course well the quartering's
having a mid-life crisis over them and
unpredictably yeah they sent the
thumbnail let's see quartering seven
i didn't even know the brown eminem was
supposed to be female and by the way
i don't care
does anybody even know the only eminem
characters i know are the
the peanut ones
like yellow and red uh red is not a
pinot noir
uh
uh
excuse me
can you speak more respectfully about
red that one represents child slave
labor and you need to put a little
respect on that name
okay dude you're being insensitive right
that
oh
m m's and meanings
what the hell are we going to do without
red m m's
red m m is for the red pill males
who dress up in tuxedos
forced monogamy
let me tell you something bucko the red
m m takes what he wants the green eminem
forced monogamy
i bet you didn't know that i catch that
[ __ ] looking at the yellow m m i'm
gonna stomp her
[Music]
she wants material goods and i want sex
it's just the way the world works bucko
[Music]
[ __ ] psychopath dude literally
cartoon characters that's the m eminem's
everyone knows
i don't know about all these other ones
the green eminem will also be better
represented to reflect confidence and
empowerment as a strong female first of
all let's just talk about how dumb it is
right that mars is trying to do some
[ __ ] that it's like it's a [ __ ] candy
you literally have slaves child slaves
making your game i'm gonna say
so we should keep watching the clip but
so far i don't necessarily disagree with
what jeremy is saying well i think what
it is stupid
it's stupid
but then they're making it into woke
culture right the real problem no in the
tucker
these corporations
are [ __ ] pathetic
they're literally doing crimes against
humanity and then trying to tell me that
like green eminem
isn't wearing stilettos anymore because
women need to be empowered it's like
it's pathetic but they're they're
missing the point
and known for much more than her boots
is she going to have a shaved side head
haircut
because i assume that's what it's going
to be
showcasing a force supporting women
who what what is even happening
who
who buys m ms and ever thinks about this
by the way who even buys m m's anymore
according to mars the orange m m is one
of the most relatable characters with
gen z are m m's played out of course it
is it's the one that's a complete mess
mars will also include imagery of the m
ms in
all shapes and sizes
well i want my m ms to be different
shapes in my in the bag when i buy them
then because just like we're all
beautiful snowflakes i want my m m's to
also have infinite designs i mean i
guess now i kind of want some but the
dark see it's working
and also guess what they are different
shapes and sizes in the bag so but so
you know he doesn't go the next level in
his thinking
right he just takes the culture war bait
right and he doesn't go corporations
these huge corporations are literally
[ __ ] on our [ __ ] faces using woke
whatever cultural
[ __ ] governors on
to pretend like they don't have child
slaves
that's the real story here
also
i did a little
a little digging
and um
i think the m m should have been
cancelled decades ago oh
i'm pulling it up right now yeah
all right what is this 1995 eminem blue
blue blue yes it's true
[Music]
i want to be in this commercial you
ain't getting this job because you're
not blue green
oh look at that oh they even got baby
king singing so pause it for a second
okay
the blue m m in this area of advertising
was clearly coded as being
african-american
really yes wait hold on let me let me he
plays the blues he's wearing the ray
charles glasses he's performing now
the blues blue right
i mean it's a pun obviously but do they
inherit okay now watch what happens next
[Music]
they've got blue face they got blue face
on dude
oh they called him out the audience
called him out for doing blue face yeah
whoa crowd it's a king ate him one bite
saw with my own eyes
pretty [ __ ] right yeah that's that's
very damaging
i mean i just want to know did they walk
by this child uh
the child slave
pit there in the background i want to be
in this commercial
yeah
that's john goodman the yellow who's the
red his voice in the red dan
didn't you say you searched us
i don't know no i just recognized john
goodman's voice yeah i don't know who
the other one is
how long we've been going
uh three hours
well we've done the main stories we or
we didn't do the metaverse actually [ __ ]
that's all right
ace family click baiting their son that
was good
there's a cav cav update oh that oh my
god that he's coming after you
yeah i mean we've talked about it a
little bit on this show i don't think we
talked about
love yeah how he messaged love and [ __ ]
yeah maybe we didn't mention that yeah
i think it deserves more
did you ever message him back or
anything yeah i asked him what's up did
he respond no oh yeah
he's just trying to scare you i guess
yeah it's just trying to scare me you
don't want the beast don't scare any of
us okay
oh the other one is john lovitz by the
way and the chad's saying oh okay the
only person you scare ryan kavanaugh is
your lawyers about what dumbass thing
you're going to say next
new elephants what'd you post
oh yeah these are awesome
the little baby
uh teddy bear sweater so cool
yeah
that's very
looks kind of big though
dorbz
well brucey
well maybe we should just [ __ ] to
lightly touch on the metaverse since
we're here
we can always save it
because it's in the title already oh
not that anyone gives a [ __ ] this is
enough to justify being on the title
that's a good point
you know we got a we got a lot to
prepare for for um
uh this [ __ ] it's just one clip let
me just watch
so this guy posted he goes this is that
metaverse a live rave happening right
now
in decentral land
he's talking about how amazing it is
there's a live rave it's off the rails
check this [ __ ] out dude is this
copyrighted music or just random [ __ ]
lit well i mean that's that dj so maybe
i'll just turn it down a lot
i mean whoever's playing the
yes the nft race look at this [ __ ] it's
off the
chains this guy posted this he's like
this is insane the future
this is like a shittier version of of
third life
second life well no
no i guess second life was super super
popular back back in the day so this is
basic
i can't believe people are actually like
hyping up the metaverse it's
so [ __ ] dumb
it's so dumb it's literally just
like a basic vr game
second life
it's nothing it's nothing
on the meat show
i mean it's just people like garyvee who
stand to profit who already like
scheming to profit off it but you need
an nft to get into this party
damn this looks so lit yeah this is lit
i want to be at that party do you want a
major foam so you you could actually
i believe i have it right under there um
yeah here this that i highlighted that's
you can uh
hop in can we take a second yeah create
yourself last guest sure don't i need a
vr set or something oh dumb
this
how is this the metaverse this is the
metaverse this is a new thing this is
not at all reinventing the wheel just
playscentdecentraland.org
wow this is dude the customization you
can create a character
yo look at the customization no freaking
way
shittier [ __ ] literally never seen
nintendo me
yeah
no freaking way dude it's like crazy
this is a whole new world about unibrow
no freaking way
whoa i feel the rave you guys feel that
i feel it coming here we go
yeah bro i can finally be the off the
handsome chad i always wanted to be
you look great
yo such a chad
someone said can't wait for the mlk
nightclub drop
i have a dream
shout out to this one goes out to george
floyd now that would be a rager
is my guy
this is crazy right now
let's join this world
hop
i think i skipped i think i just hit
next in it yeah right at aol.com
yo i'm in i'm about to invest everything
i have
into this metaverse here we are wow it's
like a [ __ ] you know this reminds me of
like a video game that comes in your
cereal box
hey don't
checks adventure or whatever their chex
man was uh what happened like
learning to spell with captain crunch
chex quest
yeah
wait what happened
jump in oh it crashed jump in
yo the metaverse is happening right now
yo garyvee says i should turn my house
into an nft and put it in the metaverse
that's sick that's such a good way to
make money
you heard a chex quest
yeah
the [ __ ] was way better than this to be
honest
the cereal box game from 1994
yo no way you got it where is the
freaking metaverse people are probably
joining from the show we're probably
gonna crash this [ __ ] everybody hop on
the freaking metaverse this is insane
wow
freaking no way how do i
just type
standard chat what's up ask where you
can get oh i can use my mic hold on
no freaking way dude this is crazy this
is like the real world
that's where you can find a gun
where i got a gun about to mass shoot
this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
wait so there's a way to speak
oh freaking waited i think they're
hearing you wait no way can they hear me
i think so
well i mean it has to use the mic
dude can you guys hear me or what
yo
this is crazy this is the metaverse
oh come on i don't think it i don't hear
anyone else talking
they're all too shy
yellow don't be so shy you guys the
metaverse
close the tab behind hi i can type
hi
is there a mute button top or bottom
left the microphone use button yeah okay
no it's enough to work
hey guys dude this is crazy right now
wait oh my god this is such dog [ __ ]
yo this is like fortnight without the
guns it's free crazy it's like real life
this is awesome bro
look how you have like a crosshair in
the middle of the screen yeah i wanted
about to do a school shooting up in this
you guys
somebody better talk to me before i
start to get uh blackpill
wait wait wait i genuinely need to
figure out how to talk to these guys
wait look at the bottom left you see the
little red x that might be like i don't
know how to click because it just oh it
won't release your mouse hit enter maybe
there you go okay
click that oh i have to hold it you have
to hold it yeah you guys this is crazy
right now
yeah this is the metaverse you all
freaking out right now like me
yo look at this guy
he's glowing and [ __ ] he's got angel's
wings
it's so the controls are so hard
it's like so hard
okay and then to type
all those wings are sick right now
where'd you get those dude
i don't hear anyone else talking someone
else they're gonna be they're just shy
yo you better say something to me
you're starting to feel bad you're not
talking to me dude let's some of you
guys are cool you should uh stay out of
the metaverse tomorrow
yo
yo i like you guys don't come to the
metaverse tomorrow okay
yo come on guys seriously say something
to me
this is the metaverse uh let's let's
let's come on let's let's chat yo what's
up daytripper
yo what's up daytrip guys come on
seriously hello let's talk hello hello
something's not happening i'm not
getting the social experience
this is not the social experience i was
promised you guys
ryan cavanaugh i wonder okay
yeah ryan kavanagh talked to him
in the metaverse
yo kavanagh
talk to me baby
ryan say what's up
yo there's something wrong i don't think
i mean i see it registering the levels
on that mic symbol but i'm not hearing
anyone else
but we we're hearing like the pitter
patter of them walking around foot
soldier said this is the future
you can press v for first person
it's like i'm seeing through his eyes
this is insane
no freaking way dude wonderbot no i can
get no robot
oh it's for sale oh i have to earn money
there's been three wonderbots minted
already yo i'm looking for a job so i
could buy a wonderbot
yo can i get an nft of an ak
yo you guys have any aks without serial
numbers
says we can hear you ethan i think
you're just yelling are you pressing
pressing t to talk
well he was hitting that oh yeah t does
talk but i was guys who could but i
can't hear anyone else talk
somebody say something i want to talk to
you guys man
this is crazy right now
oh a snowman no way
how did you do that
dude you get this little snowman real oh
i can go outside oh
questing oh can you hear me oh
interesting
yo i'm going question right now this is
crazy bro no freaking way
this is the worst thing i've ever seen
oh wait i gotta get back into town i
need to talk to somebody
oh
oh i almost crashed there
oh
guys you could do question out here
there's like stuff outside you guys
i can't hear anybody
where is ethan all right i gotta end
this
stupid huge ass
huge ass
can i climb this ladder no freaking way
if i can are there ladder physics
oh yeah they haven't implemented they
haven't minted the ladder oh i can't
climb the ladder you guys yeah
that's whack cab cabs in here
my full lobby
everyone's name is like ethan klein
something
this is crazy bro i'd rather be here
than at home with my family to be honest
it's dangerous
this is so futuristic right now
i'm about to sell all my belongings and
just buy virtual goods because that's
all the matter in the future
yo that's a real nft
yo
yo
what about this one
this one is not for sale either dude
yo how am i supposed to get
my [ __ ] portrait on the wall if none
of this shit's for sale yo
pickaxes
floods freaking go though dude is that a
minecraft reference is that a minecraft
reference to megan grant's the wear
significant
mining bonus yo
just like real life i'm gonna go
freaking mine
wait is this supposed to be like a real
life sim cause why am i mining
yo just like real life i'm about to work
the coal mines right now oh my gosh yo
no one let's [ __ ] party
start yelling at them hit t whole t
dude
oh i just saw your undies bro oh
no way
those moves are right
oh my god dude
is this an npc a real person
okay
let's go
yo i can go up here
um where is this
oh
that's where you want to be what is this
you guys there's a hologram oh there
it's some sort of like demon summoning
circle
let's go to the top you guys this is
crazy this is like the real world but
better
dude this is way better than that
[Music]
this is [ __ ] epic all right i'm done
okay
that was fun there's the metaverse guys
it's all happening
it's crazy it's real it's 20 fast it's
2022
[Applause]
turns out you can't have more than 200
people sign on to the metaverse at the
time just like real life
it's real life but better
all right thanks for watching everyone
so
we'll be back on thursday with oliver
tree unless he cancels on us again yep
which we're filming tomorrow
theoretically theoretically
what time are we well okay
disgusting
thank you guys for watching
thank you so much a good one it's been
fun
crazy one though
super nice dude oh it's my avatar
the metaverse is leaking out into the
real world who's controlling that in ian
is you're pretty good at
dude it's like real life that's what
that's that's how i see myself that's my
astral projection
right
so much hotter so much alpha
all right guys have a good week we'll
see you soon
peace and love
bro no way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you